You know, I'm here because we're doing a, we're recording a new smartless. And what you can't see is that every time I say smartless, I'm just going off mic on the L into the ESS, so I go smartless. Because it can make you, you can try it at home. Sometimes that out into the ES, you can get a little click into it, right? Like, if you say the word models, you want to just you I just go off or you don't want to you don't want to explode on your P you don't have the plosions so if you're gonna say that's perfect What you can't I just go perfect just off to the side of the mic so I don't go
你知道的，我来这里是因为我们在做，我们正在录制一期全新的 SmartLess。你可能看不到的是，每次我说 SmartLess 的时候，我都会把麦克风移开，从 L 音发到 S 音，所以我会说 SmartLess。因为它可以让你，你可以在家里试试。有时候把音发到 S 上，你会带出一点点击声，对吧？比如，如果你说 models 这个词，你想，我只是把麦克风移开，你不想，你不想在 P 音上爆音，你得避免喷麦，所以如果你要说——太完美了。你不能，我只是说“完美”，刚好在麦克风旁边，这样我就不会发出……
Perfect anyway. We're a little into the weeds. We're a little inside baseball on the V.O. World But I tell you what we are not. We are not afraid to give you an all new smartness. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
完美。不管怎样。我们有点扯远了。我们在配音界有点像内行人说内行话。但我告诉你我们不是什么。我们绝不会吝啬为你带来一档崭新的 SmartLess。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hey smart listeners, before we get into the good stuff, how about a little great stuff from Shawnee Hayes? Go Shawne. Hey smart listeners, this episode is brought to you in part by our friends at Verizon. If you're wishing for the new iPhone 15 Pro with titanium, you don't need to find a genie in a bottle or, I don't know, steal an unsuspecting kid's birthday wish.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。嘿，聪明的听众们，在我们进入正题之前，先来听听肖恩·海耶斯（Shawnee Hayes）带来的精彩内容吧？加油，肖恩。嘿，聪明的听众们，本集节目部分内容由我们的朋友 Verizon 赞助播出。如果你一直想要那款采用钛金属材质的全新 iPhone 15 Pro，你不需要去神灯里找精灵，或者，我不知道，去偷一个毫无防备的孩子生日愿望。
I get it. Verizon is making it easy to get apples latest and greatest with an amazing trade-in offer, even if your current iPhone has seen better days. Sean. Me, my phone is pristine, but you know some of us just aren't as careful. No judgment here.
我懂。Verizon 让你可以通过超棒的以旧换新优惠，轻松拥有苹果最新、最棒的产品，即使你现在的 iPhone 已经大不如前。肖恩。我的手机崭新如初，但你知道，我们当中有些人就是没那么小心。这里绝对不评判。
And look, you know Sean and I are well acquainted with the excellent service and offerings from Verizon, so believe me when I say, this upgrade deal is one for the books. Trade in any iPhone, any model, any condition, for the new iPhone 15 Pro with titanium with unlimited ultimate plan, 100% guaranteed, only on Verizon and network you can rely on. Visit a Verizon store or Verizon.com for full details. Offerance October 18th, 2023, and it's only available in the United States. Now, onto the show. So, uh, listener, you're a part of a double reboot episode.
而且听着，你知道肖恩和我对 Verizon 提供的优质服务和产品都非常熟悉，所以相信我，当我说这次的升级优惠绝对是史无前例的。用任何 iPhone、任何型号、任何状况，即可换购采用钛金属材质的全新 iPhone 15 Pro，搭配无限尊享套餐，100% 保证，仅在 Verizon 这个你可以信赖的网络上提供。访问 Verizon 门店或 Verizon.com 了解详情。优惠截至 2023 年 10 月 18 日，且仅在美国境内提供。现在，节目开始。所以，呃，听众朋友，你正在收听一期经历了“双重重启”的节目。
Um, yeah, we had two reboots. Both Will and I had to reboot this morning. Yeah. Which you are the reboot champ of our trio. I'm, yeah. For some reason, my computer is always the one that's a little, you know, it's a Dell. I love her. Great musician, bad computers.
嗯，对，我们遇到了两次重启。我和威爾今天早上都必须重启。对。而你是我们三人组中的重启冠军。我是，对。出于某种原因，我的电脑总是那种有点，你知道的，它是戴尔。我爱它。音乐才子，电脑白痴。
Yeah. I want to speak into great musician, great singer. Can I just say that within just recently, we lost a great friend, the great... Jimmy Buffett. Jimmy Buffett, yeah. And it was just such a huge loss and loved the guy. Very close friend to yours. Close friend of the whole family.
对。我想说的是，伟大的音乐家，伟大的歌手。我能说吗，就在最近，我们失去了一位伟大的朋友，伟大的……吉米·巴菲特（Jimmy Buffett）。吉米·巴菲特，对。这真的是一个巨大的损失，大家都很爱他。你非常亲密的朋友。全家都很亲密的朋友。
Yeah, I knew Jimmy a long time. I mean, we weren't best friends, but he was, we were definitely good friends and good family friends. loved the guy and- Very close friend to yours. Close friend of the whole family. Yeah, I knew Jimmy a long time. I mean, we weren't best friends, but he was, we were definitely good friends and good family friends in the kids and everybody. And in my, you know, obviously my heart goes out to Delaney and Savannah and Cameron and my dear friend Jimmy's wife, Jane.
对，我认识吉米很久了。我的意思是，我们算不上最好的朋友，但他绝对是我们的好朋友，也是非常好的家庭朋友，大家都非常爱他——你非常亲密的朋友。全家都很亲密的朋友。对，我认识吉米很久了。我的意思是，我们算不上最好的朋友，但他绝对是我们的好朋友，也是非常好的家庭朋友，和孩子们以及每个人都很好。而且在我的，你知道的，显然我的心与德兰妮（Delaney）、萨凡纳（Savannah）、卡梅伦（Cameron）以及我亲爱的朋友吉米的妻子简（Jane）同在。
Love the moral. I'll second that. Yeah, you guys know Jane, just one of the all-time greats. She's great. Yeah, super sad. Super sad. Yeah, sorry about that. And a huge, huge loss.
太感人了。我完全赞同。对，你们认识简，绝对是史上最棒的人之一。她太棒了。对，超级难过。超级难过。对，为这事感到难过。这是一个巨大、巨大的损失。
What an awesome guy apart from being an incredible singer, songwriter, just a big-hearted guy. Yeah, he's one of those guys, too, that you hear after how many friends he had. He was like, oh my God, everybody knew him, everybody loved him. Yeah, he was the most generous kind dude. And I've so many memories of him being really generous and kind, not just to me, but to my kids, especially the big kids got spent a long time with him.
除了是一位难以置信的歌手、词曲创作者之外，他还是一个极其出色的人，一个热心肠的人。对，他也是那种你听说了他有多少朋友之后会感叹的人。你会觉得，哦天哪，每个人都认识他，每个人都爱他。对，他是最慷慨、最善良的家伙。我有很多关于他非常慷慨和善良的记忆，不仅仅是对我，还有对我的孩子们，特别是大孩子们和他度过了很长时间。
Yeah, just a great example of a person that I'm sure that since this was tragically not sudden, he had time to review, I'm sure, of how he's used his years. And talk about, you know, we're all going, we're all leaving. Yeah. So like, what do you do while you're here? And how do you help people and help your family?
对，这真是人类的一个伟大榜样，我确信，既然这件事（不幸地）并非毫无征兆，他一定有时间去回顾自己是如何度过这些岁月的。并且谈论，你知道的，我们都在前进，我们终将离去。对。所以，当你在世的时候，你会做什么？你如何去帮助别人、帮助你的家庭？
And, and, and utilize your uniqueness, you know, there's only one of everybody. So he seemed to really be a poster child for that. One of the, one of the all time greats. And so, we love you, Jimmy, and we miss you already, but you are not forgotten, my friend. I love that. Yep. So right before we get to our guest, Sean,
而且，并且，并且发挥你独一无二的特质，你知道的，每个人都是独一无二的。所以他似乎真的是这方面的完美典范。史上最伟大的人物之一。所以，我们爱你，吉米，我们已经开始想念你了，但你不会被遗忘，我的朋友。我喜欢这样。没错。那么，在迎接我们的嘉宾之前，肖恩，
quickly, how are you finding your first week back from the Tabasco Theater? I mean, are you enjoying being home in LA, revisiting with your sheets, your pillows? Yes, oh my God, it's so nice. My body still thinks I need to be somewhere and perform, but I'm almost over it. Yeah, I'm about to call me,
快告诉我，你重新适应从塔巴斯科剧院（Tabasco Theater）回来的第一周感觉怎么样？我是说，你喜欢呆在洛杉矶的家中，重新使用你的床单、枕头吗？是的，天哪，太美妙了。我的身体依然以为我需要在某处进行表演，但我差不多已经缓过来了。对，我快要给他们打电话了，
because I know they wanted to do more of that call me and they said, listen, and they said, you know, Sean's leaving, but would you ever consider it? And I said, and I said, you mean coming to do Oscar Delavent? And they said, forget it, we got the wrong number. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, And they said, now, forget it, we got the wrong number. It sounds just like Oscar De La VIII.
因为我知道他们想做更多这样的通话，他们说，听着，他们说，你知道肖恩要走了，但你还会考虑吗？然后我说，然后我说，你是说去演奥斯卡·德拉伦塔（Oscar de la Renta）吗？他们说，算了，你打错电话了。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
No, I'm good. I'm happy. You mean Mario, Mario, brother. You don't take a lot of adjusting to get back into kind of just doing I do actually. I'm pretty tired. I'm, I mean, I've energy, but I'm happy. You got to the house where your slippers happen to see you. They greeted me with open arms. I put them right on. How's Ricky? How's Ricky doing? Good. Everything's good. It is weird.
不，我很好。我很开心。你是说马里奥，马里奥兄弟。你不需要花太多时间来调整就能重新开始做——我其实需要。我挺累的。我的意思是，我有精力，但我很高兴。你回到了那栋拖鞋在等着你的房子吗？它们张开双臂迎接了我。我马上就穿上了。里奇怎么样？里奇过得怎么样？很好。一切都好。这挺诡异的。
That's the dog Tracy. What's that? I was just telling Tracy that that's a dog. What Tracy knows? Tracy knows the dog. If there's one thing she, she's the aunt. Yeah. No, I'm, I'm excited. Everything's one thing she, yeah. She's the aunt. Yeah. No, I'm excited. Everything's good. Everything's good. Everything's back to normal.
那是狗狗特蕾西（Tracy）。怎么了？我刚刚在告诉特蕾西那是只狗。特蕾西知道吗？特蕾西知道那只狗。如果说她有什么，她就是个大妈。对。不，我很，我很兴奋。一切都——如果说她有什么，对。她是个大妈。对。不，我很兴奋。一切都好。一切都好。一切都恢复正常了。
It's like I was gone today. Jason's getting ready for his intro. He's still doing some copy and paste thing. No, I'm doing, I'm in a deep sweat here trying to, because of the reboot listener. Remember we talked about the reboot. Lost my notes, stirring the reboot, but I just pulled them up out of the bin.
就像我今天才离开一样。杰森正在准备他的开场白。他还在搞什么复制粘贴的东西。不，我正在弄，我在这里急得满头大汗，因为那个重启听众。还记得我们讨论过重启的事吗。在重启时弄丢了我的笔记，但我刚刚把它们从回收站里找出来了。
Great. Guest, you're safe. Okay, guest. Guest. Here we go. Here we go. We got a real superhero this morning, guys. Mm-hmm.
太好了。嘉宾，你安全了。好吧，嘉宾。嘉宾。我们来喽。我们来喽。我们今天早上迎来了真正的超级英雄，伙计们。嗯哼。
Our guest today is without dispute, one of the best athletes the world has ever seen. This is my department. And his sport of football, you might be the best we'll ever see. Wow. He is the NFL's only five time most valuable player. He's a 14 time pro ball selection.
我们今天的嘉宾毋庸置疑是世界见过的最伟大的运动员之一。这是我的领域。在美式足球这项运动中，他可能是有史以来最伟大的球员。哇。他是 NFL 唯一一位五次荣膺最有价值球员（MVP）的球星。他 14 次入选职业碗（Pro Bowl）。
It's Peyton and he. He's the first to win a Super Bowl with two different teams. He's been inducted to the Hall of Fame. And he has more individual records than we got time to mention. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother.
他是佩顿（Peyton）和他。他是第一位带领两支不同球队赢得超级碗的球员。他已经入选了名人堂。他拥有的个人纪录多得我们根本没有时间一一列举。是曼宁兄弟（The Mannings）。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。
It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's thelyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother.
是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁兄弟。是曼宁郡的教授，请欢迎威尔。佩顿来了。我的天啊，拜托。警长来了。
It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It professor at his alma mater. Please welcome Will. Paid meeting. I mean, come on. The sheriff is here.
是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。是埃莉斯的哥哥。他是母校的教授。请欢迎威尔。付费会议。我的天啊。警长来了。
Hi, Paid. You said five time. You said five time. Yeah, there's like, there's nobody left. Yeah. Oh, did you have it guest, Sean? I did. Sean had it. Part the intro. Paidon, first of all, I, of all, I've said this a lot over the years. From the first time I saw you on a sketch program of which I'm not going to mention, and throughout all the number of commercials you've done and things you've done, I have, and I don't want to embarrass you, Peyton, I think you're the best actor, athlete of all time. Of all time. I have a whole lot of time.
嗨，佩顿。你刚刚说五次。你刚刚说五次。对，这里就像，已经没有人能比了。对。哦，肖恩，你带了嘉宾来吗？我带了。肖恩带了。作为开场白的一部分。佩顿，首先，我，我这些年来经常说这件事。从我第一次在某个我不会提及名字的小品节目中看到你开始，以及在你拍过的大量商业广告和做过的各种事情中，我，我不想让你难堪，佩顿，我认为你是史上最伟大的运动员演员。史上最伟大。我有很多很多时间。
All the fame. All the fame. Awesome timing. And that's not a thin category. It the time. All the fame. Awesome. And that's not a thin category. It's not. It's a big category. And I say this not to embarrass you. Talk us a little bit how the man and cast started because I love that you guys ended up doing
名人堂。出色的时机掌握。而且这可不是一个冷门的领域。掌握时机。名人堂。太棒了。而且这可不是一个冷门的领域。真不是。这是一个很大的领域。我这么说并不是为了让你难堪。跟我们聊聊“曼宁兄弟直播”（ManningCast）是怎么开始的，因为我很喜欢你们最终做了这个节目，而且你和你弟弟每周都会出现在电视上。
it and that you're on TV every week, you and your brother. Yeah, he's awesome. How did that come about? What was the thing that you guys were like, oh shit, did somebody come to you or are you like, you like, we should be, we should be supporting our junk on TV every week. Well, yeah, it's funny because you hate to say anything good, you know, came out of the pandemic, but obviously there was a lot of things being done remotely during the pandemic, including broadcasting certainly.
对，他人太好了。这是怎么促成的呢？你们是怎么突然觉得，哦操，是有人来找你们，还是你们自己觉得，我们应该，我们应该每周把我们的废话搬上电视。好吧，对，很有趣，因为你绝不会想说，有什么好事，你知道，是源于这场大流行病的，但在大流行病期间显然有许多事情都是远程完成的，其中当然也包括转播。
And so I've been in talks with the, the doing the traditional broadcasting, right? Which I don't think people understand what that really entails, right? The Chris Collins words, the late John Madden who really created it, it is go to the town where the game is on Friday, watch practice, interview the home team, Saturday,
所以，我当时一直在和，进行传统转播的洽谈，对吧？我不认为人们真正理解那到底意味着什么，对吧？像克里斯·柯林斯沃思（Chris Collinsworth），以及真正开创这种形式的已故约翰·马登（John Madden），他们要在周五前往比赛所在的城市，观看训练，采访主队，周六，
visit with the visiting team coming in, and then sit around all day Sunday or Sunday night, or even Monday to do the game. And then when you get back home, you're really not home because you better be studying where the left guard went to high school. And what is 40 time is. I mean, you have to know more than a quarterback would,
探访客队，然后从周日一整天，到周日晚上，甚至周一都坐在那儿转播比赛。而当你回到家时，你其实也回不了家，因为你最好去研究一下左卫是从哪所高中毕业的。他的 40 码冲刺跑成绩是多少。我的意思是，你必须了解得比四分卫还多，
quarterback just hasn't know the defense, right? A broadcaster, you got to know special teams, you got to know more than a quarterback would. quarterback just hasn't know the defense, right? A broadcaster, you got to know special teams. You got to know the depth chart. And so anyway, that's the, so that's what I did not want to do because I got young kids playing sports, wanted to be there on the weekends. My dad was at my youth basketball games,
四分卫只需要了解防守，对吧？而一个转播员，你必须了解特勤组，你必须了解得比四分卫还多。四分卫只需要了解防守，对吧？而一个转播员，你必须了解特勤组。你必须了解阵容名单。所以，总之，这就是，这就是我不想做的事情，因为我有年幼的孩子在做运动，我想在周末陪伴他们。我父亲曾出席我的青少年篮球赛、
P.W. football games, those kind of things. So that was the priority. And then, so I kind of approached the ESPN. I was like, you know, P.W. football games, those kind of things. So that was the priority. And then, so I kind of approached the SP and I was like, you know, I saw the remote things. That going to continue. I could get my brother. He's unemployed. I could get him, you know, kind of into the mix. I mean, literally, Eli, I mean, he literally thought they were joking. He's like, wait a minute, they're going to pay me to watch football with my brother from my home in New Jersey. He's like, yes, I know I went to Ole Miss, but I'm still smart of nothing though. That's a good deal. I will do that. That's how the whole family will. That's amazing. That's how it came about. And so, look, we feel like we are at a bar
青年美式足球赛，诸如此类的事情。所以那是重中之重。然后，所以我有点主动联系了 ESPN，我当时想，青年美式足球赛，诸如此类的事情。所以那是重中之重。然后，所以我有点主动联系了 ESPN，我当时想，我看到了远程连线的那套模式。这还会继续下去。我可以带上我弟弟。他处于失业状态，我可以让他，你知道的，融入进来。说实话，伊莱（Eli），我的意思是，他当时真的以为他们在开玩笑。他心想，等一下，他们要付钱让我和我在新泽西家中的哥哥一起看球？他心想，是的，我知道我毕业于密西西比大学（Ole Miss），但我还是挺聪明的，这不过是个挺不错的交易。我干。整个家族都觉得这太棒了。就是这么来的。所以，看，我们感觉就像是在酒吧里，
or on the couch watching the game together, which we would be doing anyway. And the viewers sitting there with us and our guests, they have to love football. Well, that's the number one criteria. You got to love football. And what's cool to me. We'll call it in, right? I'm supposed to call in.
或者在沙发上一边看比赛一边聊天，反正我们平时也是这么做的。观众和我们的嘉宾就坐在我们身边，他们必须热爱足球。好吧，这是第一标准。你必须热爱足球。对我来说最酷的是什么？我们会连线进来，对吧？我应该连线进来。
Yeah, we'd love to have it. We'd love to have all of it. I mean, now that Sean's an expert, you know, get a picker on the spread. Yeah, but also, but Peyton, I used to play football when I was a kid. Which is critical, which is critical to being wanted. You have to have played flag as a third grader to get on. No, no, I was tackle football. Really?
对，我们很乐意。我们很乐意把所有的都连进来。我的意思是，既然肖恩现在是个专家了，你知道的，让他对分差做一个预测。对，还有，但是佩顿，我小时候也踢过美式足球。这至关重要，这对于想要上节目至关重要。你必须在三年级时踢过旗帜橄榄球（flag football）才能上节目。不，不，我是打擒抱橄榄球（tackle football）的。真的吗？
Sean, you're dead. You're dead watch your games. I heard it through the rearview mirror, right? I was driving away. A lot of stuff. A few of you. Hey, as he was driving with Sean A lot of stuff. Few of you. As he was driving with Sean's family, Sean's dad famously left his family.
肖恩，你死定了。你死定了，看你的比赛。我是从后视镜里听说的，对吧？我当时正开车离开。好多事。你们当中有几个人。嘿，当他开车和肖恩在一起时，肖恩，有很多事。你们当中有几个人。正如他开车和肖恩在一起时，肖恩的父亲以抛弃家庭而闻名。
Top speed. You know, it's funny, we started, we started a smartness during the pandemic as well. And we can't believe that anybody would want to sit around and listen to us, just shoot the shit. It seems ridiculous. Even today. It's shocking. It seems ridiculous even today. It's shocking. It's just, you know, it's different. And I think people, like I said, I think when the
极速。你知道，很有趣，我们也是在大流行病期间创立了 SmartLess。而且我们简直不敢相信会有人愿意坐下来听我们在这儿胡扯。这看起来太荒谬了。即使在今天。这太让人震惊了。即使在今天这也显得很荒谬。太震惊了。这只是，你知道的，这很不同。而且我认为人们，就像我说的，我认为当，
game's good, we're talking about the game and the game's not so good, nobody wants to hear about the third and one run play and what defense they were playing when it was a one-yard game. Like, who cares? Let's talk to, you know, Condoleezza Rice about why she likes football. So, I think the cool thing about it, Will, is that there's so many people from different backgrounds. I mean, we had President Obama last year, Condoleezza Rice Snoop Dogg is a huge football thing. He's been a youth football coach in LA for years. And you know Snoop Dogg is? Yes, I do. I do know that Snoop Dogg is., you know, I mean, it's like it, it just brings people together, which I think, which
比赛精彩时，我们就谈论比赛；如果比赛没那么精彩，没人想听什么第三档一码冲球，以及当推进了一码时他们打的是什么防守。谁在乎呢？让我们和，你知道的，康多莉扎·赖斯（Condoleezza Rice）聊聊她为什么喜欢美式足球。所以，我认为最酷的事情，威尔，是有这么多来自不同背景的人。我的意思是，我们去年请到了奥巴马总统，康多莉扎·赖斯，史努比狗狗（Snoop Dogg）也是个超级狂热的足球迷。他多年来一直在洛杉矶担任青少年足球教练。你知道史努比狗狗是谁吗？是的，我知道。我的确知道史努比狗狗是谁，你知道的，我的意思是，这就好像它，它只是把人们凝聚在了一起，我认为，我认为
is cool thing about football. And it doesn't matter what your background is or where you came from. I love football. Liverpool is my favorite team. And I watch every Saturday. And this timed out perfectly, right, Peyton, because staying at home, your kids are, your kids, are your kids 13? Yeah, they're 12th, 12, seventh grade and yeah, I mean, boy and girl twins. Like literally Monday, my daughter has a volleyball game at four o'clock mountain time that
这就是橄榄球的酷之处。而且不管你的背景如何，或者你来自哪里，这都不重要。我爱橄榄球。利物浦是我最喜欢的球队。我每个星期六都会看。时间安排得太完美了，对吧，佩顿，因为待在家里，你的孩子们，你的孩子们，孩子们13岁了吗？对，他们12岁，12岁，七年级，对，我的意思是，龙凤胎。就在周一，我女儿下午四点山地时间有一场排球赛
I'll go to. And then at five, I'll drive over to my buddy Scott's garage, which is where I film it. And do the show at 615 and I'm home at nine thirty. So how did Scott, wait, how did Scott, how did Scott's house turn into this dude? Great quick story, you know, Scott owed me a favor. When you went a football game as a quarterback, you have about 50 texts after a game.
我会去看的。然后五点钟，我开车去我死党斯科特的车库，也就是我拍节目的地方。6点15分开始录节目，9点半回家。那斯科特，等等，斯科特，等等，斯科特的房子怎么变成这样的，老兄？一个很棒的简短故事，你知道的，斯科特欠我一个人情。当你作为四分卫赢了一场比赛时，赛后你大概有50条短信。
When you lose, you have three. Your wife says she loves you. Your dad who played says, hey, tough night, I'm proud of you. Hang in there. Your other brother was a quarterback played says, hey, tough night, I'm proud of you, hang in there. Your other brother was a quarterback, Eli, hey, you know, some tough conditions, you know, get them next week. What you don't do when a quarterback loses is replay the game in the text. Like, you don't say, hey, really sorry about those four interceptions.
当你输了的时候，你只有三条。你老婆说她爱你。你那个踢过球的老爸说，嘿，今晚真艰难，我为你骄傲。坚持住。你另一个当过四分卫的兄弟说，嘿，今晚真艰难，我为你骄傲，坚持住。你另一个当过四分卫的兄弟，伊莱，嘿，你知道的，情况有点艰难，下周把他们赢回来。四分卫输球后绝对不会做的事，就是在短信里重播比赛。比如，你不会说，嘿，真的很抱歉那四个拦截。
Yes, thank you. I remember I was there. It was 20 minutes ago. My friend, Scott, you know, we've all done this. Have you ever texted someone? Accidentally you're talking about them and you text the person that you're talking about? Yes, I think your interceptions against the Bengals one night I come in. I got four texts my dad my brother my wife. I have a fourth from Scott who text says hey Do you think Peyton has money on this game? Okay?
是的，谢谢。我记得我当时在那儿。那是20分钟前的事。我的朋友斯科特，你知道的，我们都干过这事。你有没有给某人发过短信？不小心你在谈论他们，然后你把短信发给了你正在谈论的那个人？是的，我想你对阵猛虎队的那天晚上有一次我进来了。我收到了四条短信，我爸、我我哥、我老婆。我还有第四条来自斯科特，短信写着：“嘿，你觉得佩顿这场比赛压钱了吗？”好吧？
I mean, we both have been there, right? Do I respond? No, do I know it's an accident? Yes. Does Scott call me on Thursday to say, hey, my 10 year old was playing with my phone if you got a weird text? I'm like, all right, Scott,
我的意思是，我们俩都经历过，对吧？我要回复吗？不。我知道这是个意外吗？是的。斯科特周四打电话给我说，嘿，我10岁的儿子在玩我的手机，如果你收到奇怪的短信？我心想，好吧，斯科特，
if that you blamed your 10 year old son, now I have a problem with it. So 10 years later, I said, I said, dirt bad. Yes, it that you blamed your 10 year old son, now I have a problem with it. So 10 years later, I need your garage, okay? You owe me. That was mental trauma. So I'm using your garage. And that's how it came about.
如果你把责任推卸给你10岁的儿子，我现在就有意见了。所以10年后，我说，我说，太恶劣了。是的，你把责任推卸给你10岁的儿子，现在我可有意见了。所以10年后，我需要借用你的车库，好吧？你欠我的。那可是心理创伤。所以我现在用你的车库。事情就是这样来的。
No. Now, wait, no, Peyton, do you just not have the space in your studio apartment that you live in? Yes, it's tight corners in there. The equipment, I didn't know this stays there all year. I thought it was was like we're gonna pop in and we'll pop out when we come back in a couple weeks You only we only do 10 games by the way. We don't do all 17. I don't want to see Eli 17 weeks in a row via zoom And so that equipment staying there year-round didn't excite
不。等等，不，佩顿，难道只是因为你住的单身公寓没有空间吗？是的，那里的角落很逼仄。那些设备，我之前不知道它们是一整年都放在那里的。我以为就像我们偶尔来一下，过几周再回来。而且你知道的，我们只做10场比赛。我们不做全部17场。我不想连续17周通过缩放软件（Zoom）看到伊莱。所以这些设备全年留在那里的事并没有让
Ashley we were doing a little house construction. So that's why I called Scott garage Eli does it from his back house in New Jersey Scott's got an extra man cave, right? He does he does which is not a not a cool word to use on TV So we say garage. Yeah, it's not a yeah exactly Jason. How dare you there might be some good tax implications for Scott too I imagine that we I don't really know what what he gets out of it He wants to come like before the game. I don't let him what he gets out of it. He wants to come like before the game. I don't let him come, I'm gonna come like twice, two out of the 10 games, he gets to come by.
阿什利感到兴奋，我们在进行一些房屋改造。这就是我借用斯科特车库的原因。伊莱是从他在新泽西的后屋录的，斯科特有一个额外的“男人洞穴”（man cave），对吧？他确实有，他确实有，这个词在电视上用可不太酷。所以我们叫它车库。对，这可不是一个，对，完全没错，杰森。你怎么敢这么说，斯科特可能还能因此得到一些不错的税务减免，我猜我们，我其实不知道他能从中得到什么。他想在比赛前过来，我才不让他来，他想来大概两次，10场比赛里来两场，他有机会过来。
Which I think is coming to his own crowd. He needs to vacate his home. Does he have children or pads? He does it, he does it live there. You know, at least that I know, he's a car collector, but that's where it is. But yeah, I think two games is plenty. It's good.
我觉得这就像是来他自己的地盘看热闹。他得腾出自己的家。他有孩子或者宠物吗？他确实在那儿，他确实在那儿直播。你知道的，据我所知，他是个汽车收藏家，但情况就是这样。不过是的，两场比赛就足够了。挺好的。
You got to get him on. You got to get him on. Oh, God, but he liked that. He would like that so much. He obviously likes football, because he was watching that Bingham's game in the fourth quarter after an already thrown four in reception. So it's clear that he's a fan.
你得让他上节目。你得让他上节目。哦，天哪，但他会喜欢的。他会非常喜欢的。他显然很喜欢橄榄球，因为在已经送出四次传球拦截之后，他还在第四节看那场猛虎队的比赛。所以很明显他是个球迷。
That is so good. We'll be right back. Smartless is sponsored by Better Help. Okay. You know, there have been times where I knew that stuff was going on and even though my sort of intellectually I could understand that I was going through something, it was still tough for me to reconcile things. Like, I just like dwell on like some part of my life that wasn't amazing.
太棒了。我们马上回来。Smartless由Better Help赞助。好吧。你知道，有时候我知道事情正在发生，尽管从某种程度上说，在理智上我能理解我正在经历一些事情，但要我和这些事情和解对我来说仍然很艰难。比如，我就是喜欢纠结于我生活中某个并不那么精彩的部分。
And it would threaten to kind of upset the whole apple cart, if you will. And it's like that idea of like, do you ever feel like your brain is getting in its own way? And for me, I do. And therapy was the thing that eliminated that or helped me move through that. You know, it's like that thing of like what you know what you should do, what's good for you, but you just can't do it.
而且它甚至会威胁到把整辆运苹果的车都给弄翻，如果你懂我的意思的话。这就好比那种想法——你有没有觉得你的大脑总是在给自己制造阻碍？对我来说，我确实有这种感觉。而心理咨询就是那个消除这种阻碍或者帮助我度过难关的东西。你知道，这就好像你知道自己该做什么，什么对你有益，但你就是做不到。
And I don't know, therapy helps you figure out what's holding you back so you can work for yourself instead of against yourself. Give better help a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient and flexible and suited to your schedule. All you got to do is fill out a questionnaire and you get matched to a licensed therapist. And you can switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. So make your brain your friend with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today
我不知道，心理咨询能帮你找出是什么在拖你的后腿，这样你就能为自己而战，而不是与自己作对。去试试Better Help吧。它完全在线上，旨在提供便捷、灵活的服务，并且能够适应你的日程安排。你只需要填写一份问卷，就能匹配到一位有资质的心理治疗师。而且你可以随时更换治疗师，无需额外费用。所以，用Better Help让你的大脑成为你的朋友吧。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜线smartless
to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp. H-E-L-P. dot com slash smartless. Thanks to Viori clothing for supporting the show. Viori makes premium performance apparel inspired by the act of coastal California lifestyle and you know, it's an integration of fitness
来获取你第一个月10%的折扣。网址是betterhelp点com斜线smartless。感谢Viori服装对本节目的支持。Viori制作高端功能性服饰，灵感源自加州海岸充满活力的生活方式，你知道的，它是健身、
and surf and sport and art and all this stuff, you know, designed to work out in, but doesn't feel or look like it, which I get and they do a really good job of that, but what they don't mention is, and all those things, they're not like, also made for podcasting. Viori're not like also made for podcasting. Viewers close are really good for podcasting, okay?
冲浪、运动、艺术以及所有这些元素的融合，你知道的，它的设计适合运动时穿，但感觉上和看起来并不完全是那样，我懂，他们在这方面做得真的很好，但他们没提到的是，所有这些东西，它们可不是也为播客节目制作的。Viori的服装可不是也为播客制作的。Viori的服装真的很适合播客节目，好吧？
You want to sit in a stuffy studio and you want to wear a pair of shorts that are gonna feel like crap, you know? They got your fucking nuts all twisted up. Or do you want to be in a core short? You want to feel comfortable and a short that moves the way that you move, and that you know as soon as you get out of this podcast
你想坐闷热的录音棚里，然后穿一条穿起来感觉糟糕透顶的短裤吗？你知道的。那会把你的该死的蛋蛋勒得变了形。还是说你想穿一条核心短裤（core short）？你想感觉舒适，穿着一条能随着你的动作而伸展的短裤，而且你知道只要你结束了这个播客
that you're gonna go and you're gonna hit the streets, you're gonna work out, you're gonna be doing unorthodox stuff, you know, railway ties and waist deep snow and bags of sand, you know? Working out, I'm not like one of these California workout guys in some flimsy gym. I'm doing real guys stuff. I'm street fighting, okay?
你就会马上去街上，去健身，去做一些不寻常的训练，你知道的？铁路枕木、齐腰深的雪袋以及沙袋，你知道的？进行健身训练，我可不是加州那种在某个轻飘飘的健身房里锻炼的小白脸。我在做真正的纯爷们儿的事。我在街头格斗，好吗？
I'm climbing trees, okay? I'm chasing bears, they're not chasing me. We've been fans of Viori for a long time. So we're excited to tell you about one of their newest products. The men's core jogger, hold up. It's everything you love about the core short. The same moisture wicking, stretch woven fabric, an interior box brief liner
我在爬树，好吗？我在追着熊跑，而不是它们追我。我们一直是Viori的忠实粉丝。所以我们很高兴向大家介绍他们最新的产品之一。男士核心慢跑裤（core jogger），等等。它具备你所钟爱核心短裤的一切优点。同样具备吸湿排汗、弹力梭织面料，以及内置的平角内衬裤，
for the ultimate in-go anywhere comfort. But it's all of that stuff. Now on a jogger. You lucky sons of guns. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listener, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Yeah. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet of Viori.com slash smartless. That's B-U-O-R-I.com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off
带来无与伦比的“走到哪穿到哪”的舒适感。但所有这些优点，现在都被运用到了一条慢跑裤上。你们这些幸运的家伙。投资Viori就是投资你的幸福。为我们的听众提供首笔订单8折优惠。对。去Viori.com斜线smartless给自己买一些地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装吧。也就是B-U-O-R-I.com斜线smartless。你不仅可以享受
your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash SmartLess and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Hey SmartLess listener, this episode is brought to you in part by FanDuel. Score early this NFL season with FanDool America's number one sports book because right now new customers get $150 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's $150 in bonus bets winner lose. If you've been thinking about joining
首单8折优惠，还可以享受美国境内满75美元免运费以及免费退货服务。快去Viori.com斜线SmartLess，探索Viori服装的多功能性吧。嘿，SmartLess的听众们，本期节目部分由FanDuel为您呈现。在这个NFL赛季抢先得分，选择全美排名第一的体育博彩公司FanDuel，因为现在新用户只要下注5美元，就能保证获得150美元的奖金投注。无论输赢，都有150美元的奖金投注。如果你一直在考虑加入
Fandool, there's no better time to get in on the action. The app is so easy to use. There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads and player props and overunders and more. Here's the thing about using Fandall. It's a great way to bet on the things you like. And I would like to bet on some of the things that I would like. First of all, I wish we could have bet on Sean when he was on Broadway. I wish we could have bet on Sean when he was on Broadway.
FanDuel，现在正是加入的最佳时机。这个app非常容易使用。有广泛的投注选项，包括分差（spreads）、球员表现道具（player props）、大小盘（overunders）等等。使用FanDuel的好处在于，这是对你喜欢的事物进行投注的好方法。而我也想对我喜欢的一些事情进行投注。首先，我真希望肖恩在百老汇演出的时候我们能对他下注。我真希望肖恩在百老汇演出的时候我们能对他下注。
Like I wanted to bet on him like tripping and falling. Bet on him going up on one of his pieces of dialogue. Bet on him playing the wrong note when he was on the piano. That would have been fun. But anyway, if you are a fan of doing all these things that I talked about, Fandals the place to do it. So visit fandool.com slash smartless and kick off the NFL season. Fandool official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusion supply.
比如我想赌他绊倒并摔个狗吃屎。赌他背错其中一段台词。赌他在弹钢琴时弹错音符。那一定很有趣。不过总之，如果你喜欢我刚才说的所有这些事情，FanDuel就是你的不二之选。所以请访问fandool.com斜线smartless，开启你的NFL赛季吧。FanDuel是NFL的官方合作伙伴，21岁以上且受相关条款限制。
C show notes for full disclaimer. All right, back to the show. So Peyton, when you went, I was curious to what Will was saying before about going from football to going from, you know, football to acting or, you know, just kind of all around personality. What was it like to go, what was it like your first time when someone was like, hey, we want you to do this commercial or this thing or whatever it was, whatever you first thing and how awkward it must have been not being an actor to kind of look at the camera.
完整免责声明请参见节目注释。好了，回到节目中。所以佩顿，当你去的时候，我很好奇维尔刚才说的关于从橄榄球转到，你知道的，从橄榄球转到演戏，或者，你知道的，只是全方位的性格转变。当你第一次听到有人说“嘿，我们想让你拍这个广告或者做这个东西，不管是什么，不管你的第一个项目是什么”时，那种感觉是怎样的？作为一个非专业演员，看着镜头一定觉得很尴尬吧？
Like, this is bizarre. I don't know if I want this. Like, or was it something you wanted and you're like, I can do this. What do I do? You know, what was the feeling like? Yeah, it's never really something that I, I guess, wanted or thought that I was gonna be able to do.
就好像，“这太诡异了。我不知道我想要这个。”或者这其实是你梦寐以求的，然后心想，“我能做到这个。我该做什么？”你知道，当时的感觉是怎样的？是的，这其实从来都不是我所追求的，或者说我想过、觉得自己能够做到的事情。
You know, you play quarterback and all of a sudden, you start getting asked to do a few different things. I think I want you to come speak to a school, right? And certainly do interviews. Now, I will say my dad having played a great argument for 14 years, Sean, that helped me, right? I mean, I think my dad helped me as much with things off the field that come with being in a quarterback as opposed to just on the field. I mean, he always said, do your interviews after you lose. Sign autographs. Yeah. And is that something you have to hone
你知道的，你当了四分卫，然后突然之间，人们开始邀请你做一些不同的事情。我想我希望你能去学校做个演讲，对吧？当然还有接受采访。不过话说回来，我爸爸打了14年的四分卫，这给了我很好的经验，肖恩，这对我很有帮助，对吧？我的意思是，我觉得我爸爸在处理场外伴随着四分卫身份而来的事情上，对我的帮助甚至不亚于在场上。我的意思是，他总是说，输球后一定要接受采访。要给粉丝签名。是的。那这是你需要磨练的技能吗？
being able to interview and stuff like that? Yeah, I think so. Yeah, I mean, you try to, I still say, uh, and you know too much and he's always still to this day. My dad texts me in Eli at halftime with like a full, you know, grade of the film. Like Peyton, you know, put saying,
比如如何接受采访之类的事情？是的，我想是的。是的，我的意思是，你试着，我还是会说，呃，你知道的太多了，而且他直到今天依然如此。我爸会在中场休息时发短信给我和伊莱，对比赛录像进行全面的，你知道的，评分。比如佩顿，你知道的，说，
uh, good saying, you know, I mean, it's like literally, it's a feel like we're back in kids. quit saying uh, good saying, you know, I mean, it's like literally, it's a feel like we're back in kids. So uh, the commercials, look, um, you know, I remember we'll, you know, saying that to me, people told me, hey, boy, you have good timing.
呃，说得好，你知道的，我的意思是，这感觉就像，字面意思，感觉我们就像回到了小时候。所以，呃，那些广告，听着，呃，你知道的，我记得维尔，你知道的，曾对我说过，人们对我说，嘿，小子，你的节奏感真好。
I'm like, yeah, I try to throw the ball on time, try to hit the receiver out of the break. They're like, no, in commercials. And so I don't really know what that means, but I know that I like to laugh. I know that my brothers made fun of me a lot and I laughed at that and I would dish it back.
我心想，对啊，我努力在正确的时间传球，努力在接球手变向的瞬间把球传到位。他们说，不，是在拍广告的时候。所以我其实不太明白那是什么意思，但我知道我喜欢笑。我知道我的兄弟们经常取笑我，而我对此付诸一笑，然后我也会反击回去。
I know that in an NFL locker room, Sean, you better have thick skin, you better be able to take it. And so for a football player to take their helmet off and show that they don't take themselves too seriously, I guess that's kind of what I think about. But by no means don't insult acting by saying I'm an actor, right? I'm a ex-joc that can read a script and can say the line in the way I would normally
我知道在NFL的更衣室里，肖恩，你最好脸皮厚一点，你得经得起开玩笑。所以对于一个橄榄球运动员来说，摘下头盔，表现出他们并没有把自己看得太重，我想这差不多就是我所想的。但千万不要说我是个演员，这是对演艺工作的侮辱，好吗？我只是个能读剧本、并能以我平常的语气
say it. I think that kind of helps. But you've got an infectious comfort with your own skin that doesn't seem like it's something that's new. That's what I think. I think that is, and Peyton, you said it, I think it is that you get the sense that you don't take yourself too seriously, which is great. And having that ability to be able to laugh at yourself is key to it, especially obviously
说出台词的退役运动员。我觉得这挺有帮助的。但你有一种对自己感到极其自在的感染力，这看起来不像是装出来的。我是这么想的。我觉得是这样的，而且佩顿你刚才也说过了，我觉得给人的感觉是你没有把自己看得太重，这太棒了。能够拥有嘲笑自己的能力是关键所在，尤其是显然
in comedy, not that I'm an expert on comedy, but I think that that is a big part of it. Also, you're not unused to pressure situations. You've been in a few. Right. Right. So when they go action, you're like, okay, I mean, I'm shooting a commercial or I'm doing a thing that's, yeah, I was in the fucking super, I went to Super Bulls. Like, yeah, that's a lot of pressure.
在喜剧领域，虽然我不是喜剧专家，但我认为这是非常重要的一部分。而且，你对充满压力的局面并不陌生。你经历过不少。没错。没错。所以当他们喊“开拍”时，你会想，好吧，我的意思是，我在拍广告或者在做一件事情，这，好吧，我可是参加过超级碗的，我去过超级碗。就像，是的，那压力可太大了。
I mean, the one thing, and like I said, you know, football is live. And you mentioned a certain show that, you know, it's also live. And I wasn't necessarily that nervous when I did that because I screwed up live so many times. I mean, I think six interceptions against the Chargers one night would have thrown seven easily. Thank God, you're in at a time. And so- I just texted you about that. You did? You remember that game? Yeah. I just want to remind you about those types of things. Yeah, thanks for bringing up all my highlights on this show. And so, you know, I guess when you're used to doing live
我的意思是，有一件事，就像我说的，你知道的，橄榄球是现场直播的。你提到了某个节目，你知道的，它也是现场直播的。我做那个的时候其实并不是那么紧张，因为我直播时搞砸过太多次了。我的意思是，我觉得有一天晚上对阵闪电队时有六次传球被拦截，如果再多传一次就能轻松达到七次了。谢天谢地，你是在特定时间上场的。所以——我刚刚还发短信跟你提过这事呢。是吗？你还记得那场比赛？对。我只是想提醒你一下那种事情。对，谢谢你在节目里提起我所有的的高光时刻。所以，你知道的，我想当你习惯了做直播
and screwing up live, that when you know you can read a line and have a chance to do it again in a commercial, if it doesn't go well, I guess that certainly makes it a little less stressful for me. But I'm pretty coachable, I will say. When the guy says, here's what I want you to say, my Tennessee education goes as far as, at least being able to follow those instructions.
并且在直播中搞砸时，当你知道在拍广告时你可以念台词并且如果没演好还有机会重来一次的话，我想这确实让我感到压力小了一些。但我还挺听劝的，我得这么说。当导演说，“这就是我希望你说的”，我的田纳西教育水平至少能让我听从这些指令。
Right, right. I remember that, because I remember when you did that show, and I remember my ex, my ex-wife, Amy, we talked about, we were like, man, I didn't talk to you. I wasn't famous yet then, so nobody wanted to talk, none of the guests wanted to talk to me yet, none of the hosts, but I remember us talking about it at the time and being like, man, he was so good and relaxed. That was what it was, is you were really relaxed.
对，对。我记得那个，因为我记得你做那个节目的时候，我还记得我的前妻，我前妻艾米，我们当时聊过，我们觉得，“天哪，我当时没跟你说话。”我当时还没那么出名，所以没人想说话，没有嘉宾想跟我说话，也没有主持人想理我，但我记得我们当时在讨论这件事，还说：“天哪，他表现得太棒了，太放松了。”这就是重点，你当时真的很放松。
Yeah, which is cute. I mean, that was easy to be relaxed because I was around some incredibly talented people. I think the favorite part about that particular show was being, I got to go in the huddle with, you know, in a football game, Will, you don't get to have a 12th guy in the huddle, right? You don't get to have a shadow for the day. I'm like, hey, you're in the way. Get out of the, you know, running back's path.
对，这挺可爱的。我的意思是，要保持放松其实很容易，因为我身边都是一些才华横溢的人。我觉得关于那个特定节目，我最喜欢的部分是能够加入聚商（huddle）。你知道的，在橄榄球比赛中，维尔，你可不能在聚商里塞第12个人，对吧？你不能带个替身过一天。我心想：“嘿，你挡路了。离跑卫的路线远点。”
And so, and that deal, I love going behind the ropes in a different field. And so, that's kind of what's been fascinating to me in some of the different things I've gotten to do. But you definitely needed to find a confidence and a sense of peace with being the center of something and being comfortable with basically having the ball. You ask for the ball.
所以，那一笔交易，我喜欢涉足不同的领域并深入幕后。所以，这就是我从事过的不同事情中让我觉得着迷的地方。但你绝对需要在成为众人焦点、掌控全局（也就是基本上由你来控球）这件事上找到自信和内心的平静。你得主动要求控球。
So for the people who don't play football, can you put it in the risk of asking a heavy question early on, can you, what is like the most important thing that your average person should reach down and grab when they're asked to be, to go to show their excellence? What is that part of you that you tap into where you're comfortable in a leadership position
所以对于不踢美式橄榄球的人来说，冒着一开始就问一个高难度问题的风险，你能说说普通人在被要求去展现他们的卓越时，最应该从内心深处去挖掘和抓住的是什么吗？你内心深处触及的是哪一部分，才能让你在领导岗位上感到游刃有余
that you have the confidence to execute? That's a really young, is it something that you learned? Yeah, that's a good question, because I think, look, for me, it's because it goes back to kind of preparation. I mean, in football, I couldn't throw it, you know, 80 yards down the field like some of these guys can now. I mean, I think Josh Allen and my homes can literally throw 80 yards on their back foot. Couldn't outrun anybody. If you ever watch me play Sean, you should know that, right? I had a coach tell me once that I couldn't run out of sight in a week.
并且有自信去执行？这真的很年轻，这是你学来的吗？是的，这是个好问题，因为我觉得，听着，对粉丝来说，因为这可以追溯到某种准备工作。我的意思是，在橄榄球场上，我可没办法像现在某些家伙那样把球扔到80码外。我的意思是，我觉得乔什·艾伦和马霍姆斯退着步真的能扔出80码。我也跑不过任何人。肖恩，如果你看过我比赛，你就该知道，对吧？曾有个教练对我说，我连一周里转瞬即逝的风景都跑不过。
Right. That was nice. Took me a lot of field with that. But I think it means I'm not fast. And so I was like, I got to not prepare. I got to study more film than them. I got to know my place. And I was seevers and I got to be on the same page more than anybody. And so I think that preparation is served me in these other capacities. Like I am not afraid to ask questions and go, Hey, Amy, like tell me how you want me to say this. You know, tell me what you want me to do. Hey, director, what do I do? My dad used to give me quotes as a kid. And there's a great quote when he gave me when I was in high school
对。那可真动听。这花了我好大一番功夫。但我觉得这意味着我不够快。所以我当时想，我必须做好准备。我研究的比赛录像必须比他们更多。我必须了解自己的位置。我是接球手，我们必须比任何人都更有默契。所以我认为这种准备工作在我的其他工作岗位上也帮了我大忙。比如，我一点也不害怕提问，我会说：“嘿，艾米，告诉我你想让我怎么说这个。”你知道的，“告诉我你想让我做什么。嘿，导演，我该做什么？”我爸小时候经常给我讲名言。我在高中时，他送过我一句非常棒的名言
Pittsburgh Steelers head coach Chuck Nol once said pressure is something that you feel only when you don't know what the hell you're doing and Man, that just stuck with me at the time in school, but it applied to football Nervous you bet I got nervous before every game matter of fact, I think it's good to get nervous. It means you care about what happened. The pressure, that's different. I mean, you really haven't done your homework, right? That's a bad feeling. Great.
匹兹堡钢人队的主教练查克·诺尔曾说过：压力，只有在你根本不知道自己在干什么的时候才会感受到。天哪，这句话在当时上学时就深深触动了我，但它也同样适用于橄榄球。紧张吗？你猜怎么着，我每场比赛前都紧张。事实上，我觉得紧张是好事。这意味着你在乎发生的事情。而压力，那是另一回事。我的意思是，如果你真的没有做好功课，对吧？那感觉可真糟。太棒了。
So I think that's kind of what always served me well. And it kind of helps me in these other ventures that I'm doing in the second chapter. Yeah, because as a quarterback, I mean, the games I watch, it's like that, they're always like Jason just said, you're always the leader. Like you have to have that DNA, that build in order not just to be a great player,
所以我认为这正是一直以来对我很有帮助的地方，它也在我第二人生阶段所从事的其他事业中帮到了我。是的，因为作为四分卫，我的意思是，我看过的比赛，就像贾森刚才说的，你总是那个领导者。就像你必须具备那种DNA、那种特质，才能不仅成为一个伟大的球员，
but to lead and by example, right? It takes a certain intelligence too. And I'm sure it's rare that's why there's so many heart, it's hard to find so many things. I'm biased, it's a hard position. Yeah, I mean when you play I think you got to sign up for all of it You got to accept the one it's a big job when you don't win and when you win You got to you know share the credit with others and it's there's no question. It's not for everybody Can I ask a question about a certain play? Sorry Jay and then I'm no good
还能以身作则去领导大家，对吧？这也需要一定的智慧。而且我相信这很罕见，这就是为什么有那么多……很难找到这么多这样的人。我有偏见，这真是一个很难的位置。是的，我的意思是当你上场时，我想你得接受这一切。你得接受：这是一项重大工作，当你没赢的时候，以及当你赢的时候，你得，你知道的，与他人分享荣誉，毫无疑问，这份工作并不适合所有人。关于某个特定的战术，我可以问个问题吗？抱歉，杰伊，然后我就不问了
You know because I really do love football. I've talked to the guys about this. What has the hot, hot, hot beans. Oh, go ahead. And then ask him about Omaha. And why numbers? 23. 46, hike. No, but, you know, I am fascinated by the science of it, like by the talent and the science of you in your brain,
你知道的，因为我是真的很喜欢橄榄球。我和大伙儿聊过这个。有什么……热血沸腾的战术。哦，请继续。然后问问他关于奥马哈的事。还有为什么是数字？23、46，开球。不，但是，你知道的，我对它的科学性很着迷，比如你的大脑中的天赋和科学计算，
figuring out how hard and fast to throw the ball to reach at a certain distance, a short distance or a long distance or whatever, that fascinates me. And, but dumb, dumb question, just as a stupid spectator. Additional dumb question, I guess. They're all dumb questions. I'm always so curious when there's a play where all of the players are like, you know, stuck together, like the most dense amount of players, you always throw it to that corner when there's all these defense people around the, and then you look from
弄清楚把球扔出去需要多大的力气和速度，才能达到一定的距离，短距离还是长距离之类的，这让我着迷。但是，问个愚蠢的问题，就当是一个愚蠢的观众。还有一个额外的愚蠢问题，我想。全都是愚蠢的问题。我总是很好奇，当有一个战术，所有的球员都像，你知道的，挤在一起，就像密度最大的一群球员，你为什么总是把球扔给那个角落，当周围有所有这些防守人员的时候，然后你在
on TV, you're like, there's eight other guys wide up, like, why did you throw it to the crowded part of the field? You know what I mean? Talking about in general, are you actually saying that to paint that in general? No, like in general, in general. In general. Do you know what I mean? On TV, it always seems like, why do they just throw it to the 17 players that are
电视上看到，你会想：还有其他八个家伙大摇大摆地站在那儿，就像，你为什么要把球扔到场上拥挤的区域？你知道我的意思吗？你在说总体情况吗？你是在说总体情况吗？不，就像总体情况，总体情况。总体情况。你知道我的意思吗？在电视上，看起来总是像，为什么他们只把球扔给那17个
around the one-open guy? The open guy. And instead of that. So like the offensive lineman, the big guys, they aren't eligible to catch a pass. So that eliminates those five, right? So the left tackle might be open. But if they're open, well, he looks open, right? Because nobody's guarding him because he's not allowed.
围绕着唯一一个空位球员的人？那个空位球员。而不是扔给其他人。所以像进攻前锋，那些大块头，他们是没有资格接传球的。所以这就排除了那五个人，对吧？所以左截锋可能会处于空位。但如果他们处于空位，好吧，他看起来是空位的，对吧？因为没有人防守他，因为他不被允许。
I call him like a Sam. I got a little bit. That's a good idea. And plus Sean wants to know, well, he's not allowed. I call him like I see him. I got a little. That's a good idea. And plus Sean wants to know, well, he's the largest guy. So why wouldn't you throw it to him? He seems like he'd do well with the ball. I'll text my home after this and say, hey, the left guard, I got a feeling he's going to be open tonight.
我叫他萨姆。我有一点。是个好主意。而且肖恩想知道，好吧，他不被允许。我所见即所得。我有一点。是个好主意。而且肖恩想知道，好吧，他是最大块头的人。所以你为什么不把球扔给他呢？他看起来很适合接球。我等下会给马霍姆斯发短信说，嘿，左护锋，我有一种预感，他今晚会处于空位。
He gets the Lions. And so I'm saying, that's why you need me. Yeah. I like that. Sean, I don't know how worse. I mean, I'm not as well. but like that thing of like, you know, when players come on, they have to like literally declare their eligibility, right? Like who?
他要对阵雄狮队。所以我在想，这就是为什么你们需要我。是的。我喜欢这样。肖恩，我不知道还有多糟。我的意思是，我也不太懂。但就像那种，你知道的，当球员上场时，他们必须字面意义上声明他们的资格，对吧？比如谁？
I didn't know that. I didn't know that. At risk of boring everybody, but, you know, like there's an ounce of the rules. Yeah, I mean, there's five linemen that there's a quarterback. So there's that six. There's only five other players that are eligible to catch the pass. There are certain formations that you can line up in where an offensive lineman is eligible, but he has to tell everybody number 75 is eligible.
我不知道这个。我不知道这个。冒着让所有人觉得无聊的风险，但是，你知道的，规则里有这么一条。是的，我的意思是，有五个前锋，还有一个四分卫。所以那是六个。只有另外五个球员有资格接传球。有些特定的阵型你可以排开，在那种阵型中进攻前锋是有资格接球的，但他必须告诉所有人75号是有资格的。
So the defense hears that and they go, maybe we should just run it. Just run it. Just run it. I love that. I love that. I love that. Hey, Peyton. Um, so obviously football was, you know, a passion of yours and in your dad, Archie, who shares a great name with my son or my son
所以防守方听到这个就会想：也许我们该直接跑阵。直接跑阵。直接跑阵。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢这个了。嘿，佩顿。嗯，很显然橄榄球是，你知道的，你和你爸爸阿奇的热情所在，他和我儿子有着同样伟大的名字，或者说我儿子
shares with him. Uh, but did you name Archie after Archie, man? I did not. So do you name Archie after the cartoon? Sure did it. So did you name them after all in the family? No, man, I named them after a Scottish woodcrafter. That's the true story. A guy we used to know, a husband is named sort of good crafter. I forget what a shut the hell up. Ask your question. Ask my question, which was, um, so, you know, football has just dominated your life. It's been, or not damage. It's been such a big part of your life. But I imagine that you're a fan of other sports and I joked about football, about soccer, that the rest of the world calls football. I'm a, I love American football. I'm a massive soccer fan. I'm a massive hockey fan because I'm Canadian. What's your, what's your,
和他共享这个名字。嗯，那你给阿奇起名是因为阿奇吗？我没有。那你给阿奇起名是因为那个动画片吗？确实是。那你给阿奇起名是因为《全家福》吗？不，老兄，我给他是以一个苏格兰木艺师的名字命名的。这是个真实的故事。我们以前认识的一个家伙，一个丈夫的名字类似于木艺师。我忘了……闭上你的臭嘴。问你的问题。问我的问题，那就是，嗯，你知道的，橄榄球几乎统治了你的生活。它一直是，或者说不是统治。它一直是生活中的如此重要的一部分。但我猜你也是其他运动的球迷，我之前开玩笑说橄榄球，关于足球，世界其他地方管它叫足球。我是一个，我热爱美式橄榄球。我是个狂热的足球迷。我是个狂热的冰球迷，因为我是加拿大人。你的，你的……
your F1? And F1. Of course. Well, F1 we did. So we did a, I don't know if you guys know, but I did in, in association with Omaha. We did the first one and we're slated to do two more of these Formula One sort of, what do we call them? They're sort of like Manningcast.
还有F1？当然。嗯，F1我们做过。所以我们做了一个，我不知道你们知不知道，但我跟奥马哈合作做过。我们做了第一场，而且我们还计划再做两场这种一级方程式的，我们管它们叫什么来着？它们有点像曼宁直播室。
All through the broadcast, Megas. Yeah, all through the broadcast. Yeah. Megas. For Formula One races? Yeah. Oh, nice. Yeah, with me and Danny Riccardo, and then he went and took a seat.
贯穿整个直播的解说。是的，贯穿整个直播。对。解说。针对一级方程式赛车的？对。哦，太好了。是的，我和丹尼·里卡多一起，然后他去腾出了一个位置。
He had such a great experience doing it with Will. He went back into racing a week later, which I thought was very telling. He changed the back into out of retirement. And then he broke his hand for Danny. I actually got to take some back. But what other sport other than Formula One, what do you have a sport that you're passionate about other than football? I mean, I play golf, certainly, but look, I love sports.
他和威尔一起做这件事有着非常棒的体验。他一周后又回去赛车了，我觉得这说明了很多问题。他重返赛场，结束了退役。然后他为丹尼弄断了手。我实际上得把一些话收回。但除了F1之外，你还有什么除了橄榄球之外充满热情的运动吗？我的意思是，我当然打高尔夫球，但是听着，我热爱运动。
I love living Denver, so I mean, the nuggets, the avalanche, so I keep up with all of our local sports, grew up playing baseball, but golf would be my one kind of passion. Me and Bateman are looking for a game. He's kind of giving the run around on a tee time. No. So is that true?
我热爱住在丹佛，所以我的意思是，掘金队，雪崩队，所以我关注我们所有的本地球队，从小打棒球，但高尔夫球会是我的一种热情。我和贝特曼正在找球局。他一直在推脱开球时间。没有。所以那是真的吗？
It's been tough. It's been tough. Listen, come on. We'll play. I'll play with y'all. I'm much freer than Jason's. Now, Peyton, don't you see golf more as a game as opposed to a sport? Do you draw a distinction there between a game and a sport?
这挺难的。这挺难的。听着，来吧。我们会打的。我会和你们一起打。我比贾森自由多了。话说回来，佩顿，你不觉得高尔夫与其说是一项运动，不如说是一个游戏吗？你在游戏和运动之间划清界限吗？
Yeah. Like baseball, I consider a game not a sport. Football, I think, is a sport, basketball, I think game and a sport. Yeah. Yeah. Like baseball, I consider a game, not a sport. Football, I think, is a sport. Basketball, I think, is a sport. Baseball, more of a game. Golf, more of a game. tennis, more of a game. I've never thought about it. I mean, stuff, stuff that's a little bit slower, that's a little bit more sort of, you got to deal a little bit more in long-term strategy as opposed to quick turnaround on plays, scoring opportunities. 10 is a sport that's. Yeah.
对。比如棒球，我认为它是一个游戏而不是运动。橄榄球，我认为是一项运动，篮球，我认为既是游戏又是运动。对。对。比如棒球，我认为是一个游戏，而不是运动。橄榄球，我认为是一项运动。篮球，我认为是一项运动。棒球，更像是一个游戏。高尔夫，更像是一个游戏。网球，更像是一个游戏。我从来没想过这个。我的意思是，稍微慢一点的东西，更偏向于……你必须在长期战略上多花点心思，而不是在战术的快速转变、得分机会上。网球是一项运动，它……
I think I don't want to play with Jason now after hearing that. Oh, dude. Can I get out of here? I hear you. So he's so intense. We're in, we're after this. Sounds like a long pre-shot routine. What it sounds like.
听到这个后，我现在不想和贾森一起打球了。哦，老兄。我能离开这儿吗？我听着呢。所以他太较真了。我们就在这儿，接下来的事……听起来像是一套漫长的击球前常规动作。听起来就是这样。
Oh, dude, dude, you have no idea. Why'd you do it. You know what it's called? He even admits it's called the process. Oh, it's, it's so the process of it. Let's put it this way. I walk ahead of the group so I can start my process and not you suck up any extra time. You've never seen anybody stand over a ball longer before they actually hit and you think and as a sportsman, you're going to say, how the fuck can you even make, he plays very well, by the way. It's gotten better. Has it not gotten better?
哦，老兄，老兄，你根本不知道。你为什么这么做。你知道这叫什么吗？他甚至承认这叫“流程”。哦，它，它是这个流程。这么说吧，我走在队伍前面，这样我就可以开始我的流程，而不用你浪费任何额外的时间。你从未见过任何人站在球前比他真正击球前站得更久，你会想：作为一个运动员，你会说，他到底怎么才能打得出来？顺便说一句，他打得很好。已经变好了。难道没有变好吗？
It's gotten better. It has gotten better. I think I'd rather watch football with Sean and complain about they're not throwing to the lineman and then play golf in the same basement. I need a shot clock in golf. I think I do well with that. Sounds like it. You have gotten much you have gotten much better though. I will say that you have gotten much better. But I know because you know, I hear Peyton with if you're the if you're a four handicap, you have four swing thoughts. If you're a 20 handicap, you got 20 swing thoughts. So I think I become a little bit better in golf. And so my checklist is smaller. Jason, what are you playing at right now, Jay? My handicap. Yeah. I'm like a, what am I on 11 from the blues at our place. So it's
已经变好了。确实变好了。我想我宁愿和肖恩一起看橄榄球，抱怨他们不把球传给前锋，也不愿在同一个地下室里打高尔夫。我在高尔夫球场需要一个进攻计时器。我觉得我能用好那个。听起来是这样。不过你确实进步了很多，你进步了很多。我得这么说。但我知道，因为你知道的，我听佩顿说过，如果你是一个4差点，你脑子里有4个挥杆想法。如果你是一个20差点，你有20个挥杆想法。所以我觉得我在高尔夫上变得稍微好了一点。所以我的待办清单变短了。贾森，你现在打多少差点，杰伊？我的差点吗？是的。我差不多是，我在我们球场打蓝色发球台是什么水平来着？所以差不多是
like a seven index. Yeah. 25 words or less. What's the handicap? Thank you. It's unbelievable. Is it? Exactly. Jason, Jay, you know how you were saying sport and sport in a game. Jason's It's unbelievable, isn't it? It's unbelievable. Jason, you know how you sang sport in a sport in a game? Jason's questions are games. I know. Nice for it. I just love the sound of my voice so much, you guys.
7的差点指数。是的。25个字以内。差点是多少？谢谢。这太不可思议了。是吗？完全正确。贾森，杰伊，你知道你刚才怎么说运动和游戏的吗？贾森的……这太不可思议了，对吧？这太不可思议了。贾森，你知道你刚才怎么说运动和游戏的吗？贾森的问题就是游戏。我知道。好极了。我太喜欢听我自己的声音了，你们这些家伙。
And now, a word from her sponsor. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Framebridge, the easy and affordable way to custom frame just about anything, and we have. Well, Sean has. And I'm about to look. Framebridge has curated selection of frame styles and design experts to make it fun and easy to choose the perfect frame for your piece. And the process is very simple,
现在，听一段赞助商广告。本期《SmartLess》节目部分内容由Framebridge赞助播出，这是一种简单且价格实惠的方式，可以为几乎任何东西进行定制装裱，我们都做过。嗯，肖恩做过。而我也正准备试一试。Framebridge拥有精选的框条风格和设计专家，让选择适合你作品的完美画框变得有趣又轻松。整个过程非常简单，
the order online at frameridge.com, either upload a digital photo for them to print and frame, or mail your art in, they'll send you free, secure, prepaid packaging. Framebridge, custom frames your piece using the highest quality materials and ships it to your door for free. So, I know that Sean got two things framed and I'm happy for him.
你在frameridge.com上在线下单，要么上传一张数码照片让他们打印并装裱，要么把你的艺术品寄过去，他们会寄给你免费、安全且预付邮资的包装。Framebridge使用最高质量的材料为您定制装裱作品，并免费将其运送到您的门前。所以，我知道肖恩有两件作品被装裱了，我为他感到高兴。
I really am. I mean, I haven't thought about it a lot, but when I think about it, I'm like, yeah, I'm happy for him. Fine. I have this great photo from when I was over at Anfield, where Liverpool plays. And it's me and Yergen Klopp, obviously. And Pat Linders, he's assistant. And so what I want to do is I want to get those frames so that I can have them in my office, just to kind of remind everybody that I'm a big shot. Anyway, sad as that sounds, I still want to
我是认真的。我的意思是，我没怎么想过这件事，但当我想到的时候，我会想：是的，我为他高兴。好吧。我有一张非常棒的照片，是我在利物浦主场安菲尔德球场时拍的。画面里显然是我和尤尔根·克洛普。还有佩普·林德斯，他的助理。所以我想做的是，我想把这些照片装裱起来，这样我就可以把它们放在我的办公室里，只是为了提醒大家我是一个大人物。不管怎样，听起来虽然有点可悲，但我还是想
get it done. I'm excited to do it over at Frame Bridge because it's really easy. I've got the photos. I'm going gonna upload them to them, and then these framed photos of this amazing moments that I experience are gonna come back and I'm gonna have it in my house. Frambridge pricing is fair and transparent. Pricing is based simply upon the size of your piece and you know exactly what you'll pay upfront.
把它完成。我很兴奋能在Frame Bridge完成它，因为真的很简单。我有照片了。我打算把它们上传过去，然后这些我经历过的精彩时刻的装裱照片就会寄回来，我要把它放在我的家里。Framebridge的定价公平透明。定价完全根据你作品的尺寸而定，你提前就知道自己要付多少钱。
And now they have 19 retail stores in New York City in Boston and Philly and, in Maryland, Virginia, Chicago, Atlanta, so you can get one-on-one expert design advice and see the collection in person. Visit framebridge.com or a local frame bridge store to get started and custom frame just about anything. Thank you to State Farm for supporting this episode. Think of all the amazing things in life that are expressions of just you, for instance.
现在他们在纽约市、波士顿、费城、马里兰州、弗吉尼亚州、芝加哥、亚特兰大拥有19家零售店，因此你可以获得一对一的专家设计建议并亲自查看产品系列。访问framebridge.com或当地的framebridge商店即可开始，并为几乎任何东西进行定制装裱。感谢State Farm对本期节目的支持。想想生活中所有那些只属于你自己的精彩表达，例如：
The song you stream over and over again while you're in your 13th hour of gaming at 4 in the morning with all the lights off trying not to wake up your roommates. Or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcast that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back. Or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bowl cut from the 90s. And hopefully is everything that makes you, you, makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way. Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you
凌晨4点，房间里所有的灯都关着，尽量不吵醒室友，你在那里打了13个小时游戏时一遍又一遍循环播放的歌曲。或者你在去健身房的路上以及回来的路上最适合听的六大喜剧播客中与朋友分享的推荐。甚至是你崭新的发型，它可能是一个也可能不是史诗级的90年代蘑菇头。希望所有让你成为“你自己”的东西，都能带来改变。State Farm相信保险也应该以同样的方式运作。你的计划、你的险种选择可以由你个人定制，
and the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you like choosing to bundle your home and auto policies is what the State Farm personal price plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you. So are you ready to make things personal? Call or go to statefarm.com today
并且能够通过选择适合你的选项来选择你想要的计划，就像选择将你的房屋和汽车保险打包组合一样，这就是State Farm个人价格计划的全部意义所在。以只适合你的实惠价格获得你想要的保障。所以，你准备好让事情变得个性化了吗？今天就打电话或访问statefarm.com
to create your state farm personal price plan. Price is vary by state, option selected by customer availability and eligibility may vary. Smart lets get support from Zip Recruiter. You're putting together a team. What do you want? You need people that you can rely on,
来制定你的State Farm个人价格计划。价格因州而异，客户选择的选项、可用性和资格可能会有所不同。Smartless得到了ZipRecruiter的支持。你正在组建一个团队。你想要什么？你需要你可以信赖的人，
people who can do the job that you need to have done. And you don't wanna spend a lot of time worrying about people, you know, doing the job that you hired them to do. You wanna get the right people. You know, for us, you know, we have a whole team behind SmartLess and we need, part of our team, we need people to have the ability to laugh at yourselves, or have as a podcast, we have the loose approach
能够完成你需要他们完成的工作的人。而且你不想花大量时间去担心别人（你知道的）是否在做你雇他们去做的工作。你想找到合适的人。你知道的，对我们来说，你知道的，我们SmartLess背后有一整个团队，我们需要，作为我们团队的一部分，我们需要人们有能力嘲笑自己，或者作为一个播客，我们对嘉宾采取随性的态度，
with the guests and being honest with each other and really getting each other. So we make it seem easy, but building an amazing team is actually pretty challenging. So if you're building a team and need to hire the best people for it, you need Zip Recruiter. And right now, you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. Zip Recruiter uses smart technology to scan thousands of resumes
彼此坦诚相待，并且真正了解对方。所以我们让事情看起来很简单，但建立一个出色的团队其实相当具有挑战性。所以如果你正在组建团队并需要为其聘用最优秀的人才，你需要ZipRecruiter。现在，你可以在ziprecruiter.com/smartless上免费试用它。ZipRecruiter使用智能技术扫描数控简历
to find the most qualified people for your job. Then, Zip Recruiter lets the most qualified people for your job know they are a great match for it to encourage them to apply. Building a solid team is easier than you think with Zipper Cruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zipper Cruder get a quality candidate within the first day. Go to this exclusive web address right now to try Zippercruder 4 free. Zippercruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S. Zippercruder, the smartest way to higher. And now back to the show.
来为你找到最合格的人选。然后，ZipRecruiter会让最适合你职位的人知道他们非常匹配，从而鼓励他们申请。借助ZipRecruiter，建立一个坚实的团队比你想象的要容易。在ZipRecruiter上发布招聘信息的雇主中，有五分之四的人在第一天内就找到了优质候选人。立即访问这个专属网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。Zippercruder.com/smartless。再说一遍，那是zippercruder.com/s-m-a-r-t-l-e-s-s。Ziprecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在回到节目中。
I would love being a quarterback just so I could yell and everyone in the stadiums listening to me. Speaking of which, I want, I have a, I bet you've answered this question a million times. I want to know the relevance of Omaha as your audible call. And then also I want to hear what just a, an average play sounds like in the huddle. Okay.
我真想当个四分卫，这样我就可以大喊大叫，体育场里的每个人都会听我的。说到这里，我想要，我打赌你这个问题已经被问过一百万次了。我想知道“奥马哈”作为你的战术暗号有什么关联性。然后我还想听听在聚商（huddle）时，一个普通的战术听起来是什么样的。好吧。
Just tell me what that sounds like. And then tell me what, what, what it all means. What it means. Let's, let's go with the huddle call first. Just tell me what that sounds like. And then tell me what what it all means. What it means. Let's go with the huddle call first. Perfect. All right. Here we go. Let's go explode to gun. Double right flip zebra. Scott left. Why drag F hook. F trail alert. 52 French all easy on two on two. Ready. Break. All right. Come on. We're going to explode means we're going to start in a kind of a tight formation. We're going to explode out to the different formation, right?
就告诉我听起来是什么样的。然后告诉我，那所有这一切都意味着什么。意味着什么。我们先从聚商时的暗号开始。就告诉我听起来是什么样的。然后告诉我，那所有这一切都意味着什么。意味着什么。我们先从聚商时的暗号开始。完美。好的。我们开始。我们从开球前紧缩阵型开始，然后爆发出不同的阵型。
We're gonna make the defense react, right? Before the snap. Before the snap, right? We're gonna shift, right? Gun, shotgun, right? Double means we are gonna be in a two guys on each side formation, double, right? Trips would be trips to one side, double.
我们要让防守方做出反应，对吧？在开球前。在开球前，对吧？我们要进行换位，对吧？Gun（散击阵型），也就是双后卫散击阵型，对吧？Double（双端阵型）意味着我们要形成两边各站两个人的阵型，Double。
We're gonna go double right, which means the tight ends gonna be on the right, but we're gonna flip it it and we're going to put the guy who should be on the right with the tight end. He's going to flip to the other side, which is actually going to form a little bunch on the left. We're going to go zebra. That's he's going to go in motion. Zebra is going to tell him to go in motion. Zebra's going to tell the Z to go in and back out. There's zebra motion, right? A little eye candy for the defense, right? Scott left is the passport to show you what the defense is based on how they react to the
我们要去Double Right（右侧双端），这意味着近端锋要在右侧，但我们要把它反转过来，把本该和近端锋在右侧的家伙移到另一边，这实际上会在左侧形成一个小堆积阵型。我们要喊Zebra（斑马阵型）。那是……我们要让他去进行移动。Zebra是告诉他去进行移动。Zebra是告诉Z（外接手）向内移动然后再退出来。那是Zebra移动，对吧？给防守方的一点糖衣炮弹，对吧？Scott Left（斯科特左侧）是用来观察防守方如何对移动做出反应的暗号。
motion. It's exactly right. If the cornerback runs with the motion, that tells you it's man to man. If it is kind of bump over, that tells you it's zone. It's called a pre-snap indicator. Scott left is the passport. I see Y drag is telling the wide run of five yard drag across the field. X hook, 12 yard hook by the X. F trail is the F's gonna run a little angle right out of the back field to full back. You have the running back, you got in the back field. And then alert, 52 sprint, Jal easy is,
完全正确。如果角卫跟着移动跑，那就说明是盯人防守。如果他们有点像是平移过去，那就说明是区域联防。这被称为开球前指示器。Scott Left就是暗号。我看到Y Drag（Y战术斜跑）是告诉Y接球手在场上跑一个5码的斜线。X Hook（X战术勾手），X接球手跑一个12码的勾手路线。F Trail（F战术拖曳）是F将从后场跑一个小的角度路线，也就是全卫。你拥有跑卫，他在后场。然后Alert（警报），52 Sprint Jal Easy（52冲刺简易版）是，
if the defense is playing soft zone and you don't like it, you go alert alert alert, you've seen Tom Brady, he always says alert alert alert points to us. And you're gonna go to the second play. You're gonna run this draw play to the right to take advantage of the defense. On two, it's gonna be not on one and not on two. It's I mean, not on one.
如果防守方采用松散的区域联防而你又不喜欢，你就喊Alert Alert Alert，你见过汤姆·布雷迪，他总是喊Alert Alert Alert并指着我们。然后你要切换到第二个战术。你要往右侧跑这个抽拉战术（draw play）来利用防守方的漏洞。On two（数两下开球），将不会是数一下开球，也不是数一下。我的意思是，不是数一下。
It's gonna be on two and you're ready break. And so that's when the snow comes. So what if you call it and then what if you yell Omaha at the line, that, that says an audible and how do they know what that new play is exactly. So Omaha was really the word that meant we had changed the play. When you audible Jason, it's usually with like six seconds left, right? Because the defense is disguising the show and blitz.
将是数两下开球，然后你准备喊Break（解散）。所以这就是战术到来的时候。那么如果你喊了这个，然后如果你在进攻线大喊“奥马哈”，那，那是不是代表一个战术暗号，他们到底是怎么准确知道那个新战术是什么的？所以“奥马哈”实际上是意味着我们改变了战术的词。当你更改战术时，贾森，通常是在还剩大约六秒钟的时候，对吧？因为防守方在伪装他们的布阵和突袭。
They're not going to blitz. Obviously you're like, ah, they're not blitzing. Okay, I want to go to that second place. So I'm going to say alert alert alert. And I don't have time to go through a rhythmic cadence, which Sean alluded to earlier with the colors, right? Blue 20, blue 20, HUD hut is a normal cadence. You don't have time to say that with six seconds left. So you go alert alert alert.
他们不会突袭。显然你会想：啊，他们没有突袭。好的，我想换到第二个战术。所以我要喊Alert Alert Alert。我没有时间经历那种节奏鲜明的开球口令，肖恩刚才提到了颜色的事，对吧？Blue 20，Blue 20，Hut Hut是一个正常的口令。在只剩六秒钟的时候，你没有时间说那个。所以你喊Alert Alert Alert。
Omaha set hut, right? It tells everybody, oh, he's gone to that second play and it's just a few seconds and now we're going to snap the ball. So and you called the second play in that huddle as well. We called the second play in that huddle and we did that's all we did. So I was saying Omaha every single play. So that's how it kind of got connected with me. The microphones got turned up louder and you start a production company You know out of that because of an audible so it was a chain reaction about yelling Ozark I think that that would have that would have popped through a little bit better
Omaha Set Hut，对吧？它告诉每个人：哦，他换到了第二个战术，只需几秒钟，现在我们要开球了。所以……你在那个聚商时也喊了第二个战术吗？我们在那个聚商时喊了第二个战术，我们就是这么做的——这就是我们要做的全部。所以我每个战术都喊“奥马哈”。所以这就是它怎么和我联系在一起的。麦克风的声音被调大了，你因为一个战术暗号而创立了一家制作公司，你知道的，因为一个战术暗号？所以这就像是因为大喊“欧扎克”而产生的一连锁反应，我觉得，那样的效果可能会更好一点。
It's funny. It's funny. You say that because it's a good way to get your you know Your show your business viral marketing if you can get it into a quarterback snap cat Yeah, three syllables is kind of what it needs to be. It's rhythmic, right? Ozark would be jerky, right? And somebody might flinch. It is. Well, it was filled with jerks.
很有趣。很有趣。你这么说，因为这是让你的节目、你的生意进行病毒式营销的好方法，如果你能把它放进四分卫的开球口令里。是的，三个音节正是它需要达到的效果。它很有节奏感，对吧？Ozark（欧扎克）听起来会有点生硬，对吧？而且可能会吓到人。确实是。好吧，那里面全都是生硬的词。
It was filled with jerks. You know, will our net has got a good little, you know, flow to, what about an Audi e-tron? Audi e-tron. Audi e-tron. That sounds so forth. That's awesome. We are professional grade. We are professional grade. We are professional grade.
里面全都是生硬的词。你知道的，威勒·阿内特有一个很好的，你知道的，节奏感，奥迪e-tron怎么样？奥迪e-tron。奥迪e-tron。听起来太正式了。太棒了。我们是专业级别的。我们是专业级别的。我们是专业级别的。
You know what the other thing you can do? You can just, you can just, it's your KJK, like just kidding about the first, JK, JK, JK. That means you got it. Wait, I would, first of all, I would kill to write the new Lingo for the, for the Huddle. I would kill the right those words.
你知道你还能做什么吗？你可以，你可以……就是你的KJK，就像对第一个开玩笑一样，JK，JK，JK。这意味着你懂了。等等，我，首先，我愿付出一切来为聚商编写新的行话。我愿付出一切来写那些词。
Hey, do you hear my shunts, new gig? I would start with, okay, ready? You guys hear my shunts, new gig? Yeah, I write, I write lingo for the huddle. It'll also be, it'll start with, okay, guess what? Or here goes. Here goes, we got two jobs in a cuff on the side with a lemon twist. And instead of a hot hot hot, it would be five, six, seven, eight, and then they would snap it.
嘿，你听到我的新工作了吗？我会从……好吧，准备好了吗？你们听到我的新工作了吗？是的，我写，我为聚商写行话。它还会是……它会从“好吧，你猜怎么着”或“开始了”开始。开始了，我们手里有两个工作和一个带柠檬皮的鸡尾酒。而且取代“Hot hot hot”的将是“五、六、七、八”，然后他们就会开球。
Okay, so wait, that blows my mind all that chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin I haven't asked one question yet. Go ahead, Sean. I know. So I think that's all fascinating to me. Is it obviously different teams have different lingo, right? They don't use similar languages, different languages. That's one of quarterback's change teams. It's hard to learn. The new vocabulary, Aaron Rogers, is going to the jets this year, but he's got his call in the plays, came from Green Bay. So Aaron knows the language, he knows the verbiage. so he's going to be able to play fast and play well learning a new system is hard it takes time yeah and so that's a huge advantage for for the Jess this year.
好吧，等等，这让我大开眼界，所有这些……我还没问一个问题呢。请问，肖恩。我知道。所以我觉得这一切对我都太迷人了。显然不同的球队有不同的行话，对吧？他们不用相似的语言，用的是不同的语言。这就是为什么四分卫换球队时很难学习新词汇。亚伦·罗杰斯今年要去喷气机队了，但他有他在绿湾时形成的战术口令。所以亚伦懂这门语言，他懂这些术语。所以他将能够打得很快并且表现出色。学习一套新系统很难，需要时间。是的，所以这对喷气机队来说是一个巨大的优势。
What would you do if another quarterback started yelling Omaha as they're as they're audible barking? I I I've sent him my address I expect to check to check, you know, like a kind of cool guy on a letter of a lawyer, a little bit of passion on that, yes. Exactly. I've always wondered about this, because we do it a little bit. We're kind of carnies doing what we do, and that we move around a bunch, and you know, sometimes it sort of coincides with the school year or whatever, and kids and all that
如果另一个四分卫在场上大喊“奥马哈”作为他们的战术暗号，你会怎么做？我，我，我把我的地址发给他了。我期待收到一张支票，你知道的，就像一封来自律师信里那种很酷的家伙，带着一点激情，是的。完全正确。我一直对这个很好奇，因为我们也这么做。我们做的事有点像江湖艺人，我们到处搬迁，你知道的，有时候它刚好赶上学年什么的，还有孩子和所有那些
stuff. You start out, you're a single young man right out of college You go pro you have very successful career then you get married and then you have kids What is that life like as you're sort of the latter half of your career and your kids are growing up and you're on the road and stuff At the risk of getting two personal just what was that dynamic like and being an athlete and you've got to take care of yourself, you've got to manage your sleep, you've got to manage your diet. How does that fit in with the home life?
事情。你刚开始时是个大学刚毕业的年轻单身汉。你成为职业球员，你有着非常成功的职业生涯，然后你结婚了，然后你有了孩子。当你在职业生涯的后半段，你的孩子们在长大，而你在到处奔波的时候，那种生活是什么样的？冒着变得过于私人的风险，那种动态是怎样的？作为一名运动员，你得照顾好自己，你得管理好你的睡眠，你得管理好你的饮食。这与家庭生活是如何契合的？
Yeah, it's funny. You know, football is pretty good on travel, right? And I think people completely different than basketball or baseball. Football, you travel Saturday eight times a year, right? Just eight row games and you're back home Sunday after the game. You know, baseball. You're spending four nights in the town, basketball, you know, you're on the road. So football is actually is pretty good from that standpoint.
是的，这很有趣。你知道的，橄榄球在旅行方面相当不错，对吧？而且我认为人们完全不同于篮球或棒球。在橄榄球里，你一年有八次在周六旅行，对吧？只有八场客场比赛，比赛结束后的周日你就飞回了家。你知道的，棒球。你得在一个城市待四个晚上，篮球，你知道的，你在客场奔波。所以从这个角度来看，橄榄球其实相当不错。
We didn't have kids until basically we got the Denver toward the last half of my career. But yeah, I do think it's a challenge to look quarterback. This they say, you know, some people say I can't take it home with me. I think they're paying you to take it home with you. I think you got to really, you know, organize your time and your schedule. Hey, I'm on Tuesdays. My off day, I'm going to, you know, you know, plan these things with my, with my young kids or do some charity work, but I think kind of writing out your schedule
直到我们搬到丹佛，也就是我职业生涯的后半段，我们基本上才有了孩子。但是，是的，我确实认为这是一个挑战，看四分卫……他们说，你知道的，有些人说我无法把工作带回家。我认为他们花钱就是为了让你把工作带回家。我认为你必须真正地，你知道的，安排好你的时间和日程。嘿，周二，我的休息日，我要去，你知道的，你知道的，和我的小孩子们计划这些事情，或者做一些慈善工作，但我觉得把你的日程写下来
kind of helps quarterbacks, right? But certainly a lot of film study, a lot of things on your own. But from a family standpoint, you know, playing the NFL is actually pretty good. Yeah, interesting. So like when you, and you're used to it, because obviously again, your dad played for 14 years in NFL, so you kind of, you've seen it from both sides.
对四分卫挺有帮助的，对吧？但当然，有很多录像分析，有很多事情需要你自己做。但从家庭的角度来看，你知道的，在NFL打球其实相当不错。是的，很有意思。所以就像当你，而且你已经习惯了，因为显然还是那句话，你父亲在NFL踢了14年球，所以某种程度上，你从两边都看到了这一点。
Yeah, no, and my dad was a great, included us, you know, me and my brother, Cooper got to go to the practices on Saturdays, you know, got to go down the locker room after games. And so, you know, I think you see more quarterbacks, including their young kids and people in their lives, right? Cursons. In this quarterback show, we did, you know, head as kids in the locker room. So I can relate to that, and I love including my kids
是的，没有，而且我父亲很伟大，他把我们包括在内，你知道的，我和我哥哥库珀周六可以去训练场，你知道的，比赛结束后可以去更衣室。所以，你知道的，我觉得你能看到更多的四分卫把他们的年幼的孩子和他们生活中的人包括进来，对吧？科辛斯。在这个我们制作的关于四分卫的节目里，你知道的，有孩子在更衣室里。所以我对此感同身受，我喜欢让我的孩子
and some of the cool things of that I get to do. That's cool. What was the tension like when you were getting close to saying yes to Tennessee and not going to Ole Miss? Did you try for Ole Miss? Yeah.
参与到我能做的一些酷炫的事情中。那太酷了。当你快要对去田纳西州说“好”，而不是去密西西比大学时，当时的紧张气氛是怎样的？你为密西西比大学争取过吗？是的。
Because Peyton's dad went to Ole Miss, it was a big deal there, and then you were no slouch coming up. So what was that decision process going? It was Ole Miss interested? Yeah, they were interested. I was interested. That's kind of where I wanted to go.
因为佩顿的爸爸去了密西西比大学，那是个大事件，而且你当时也是个很优秀的年轻人。所以那个决定过程是怎样的？密西西比大学有兴趣吗？是的，他们有兴趣。我有兴趣。那差不多是我想去的地方。
Jason's where I always thought I would go. It's where I only college I ever thought existed for the majority of my life. And then you start getting recruited and you realize, oh, there are some other schools. And I got to give props to my dad. My dad said, son, you're 17 years old. You can make your own decision here, right? You decide where you want to go and you go there and I'll have your back. And he said, you're going to Ole Miss. That's where I went. That's what we're doing into the discussion. And he actually took some flak from people that he knew, for not making it. For not staring you. his own mother, which which was tough. But
贾森，那是我一直以为自己会去的地方。那是我这辈子大部分时间里以为唯一存在的大学。然后你开始被招募，你意识到：哦，还有其他一些学校。我得向我爸致敬。我爸说：“儿子，你17岁了。你可以在这里做出你自己的决定，对吧？你决定你想去哪儿，然后去那儿，我会支持你的。”然后他说：“你要去密西西比大学。那就是我要去的地方。这就是我们要做的，讨论结束。”而且他实际上还承受了他认识的人的一些抨击，因为他没有……因为没有盯着你。他自己的母亲，这挺艰难的。但是
what happened with the first the first time you played old miss? That was awkward for my from my from my parents. It's funny when the coach for Tennessee came to recruit me. That was my mom's number one question. Do y'all play Ole Miss in the next four years? And he says, no, we don't. And it was an absolute lie. We played him twice in those four years, right? Which, back then, like before the internet,
你第一次对阵密西西比大学时发生了什么？对我和我父母来说，那挺尴尬的。有趣的是，当田纳西州的教练来招募我时。那是我妈妈的头号问题：“你们在接下来的四年里会打密西西比大学吗？”他说：“不，我们不打。”这是一个彻头彻尾的谎言。我们在那四年里打了他们两次，对吧？在当时，就像在互联网出现之前，
you couldn't really check the future schedules. So how'd you do in those games? We won both, which is probably helpful. But yeah, it was tough. My dad kind of sat on his hands and wore neutral clothes. And, you know, Eli went to Ole Miss. Everybody was happy. Everybody's at peace now.
你真的无法查看未来的赛程。所以你在那些比赛中表现如何？我们都赢了，这可能很有帮助。但是的，这很艰难。我爸有点无能为力，穿着中立的衣服。而且，你知道的，伊莱去了密西西比大学。每个人都很高兴。现在每个人都平静了。
But like watching, you know, watching your dad play football when you were growing up, obviously, the question is, would you have gone into football? Like, do you just think that's, well, that's what my dad did, that's what I'm gonna do? Or, that's a great question. I think people think I'm going to do. Or that's a great question. I think people think my dad like raised quarterbacks. That was his master plan.
但是就像看着，你知道的，看着你爸爸在你成长过程中打橄榄球，显然，问题是，你会去打橄榄球吗？就像，你只是觉得那是，好吧，那是海盗我爸做的事，那也是我要做的事？或者，那是个好问题。我想人们以为我要去……或者那是个好问题。我想人们以为我爸像是在培养四分卫。那是他的总计划。
It was actually a complete opposite. He like just raised kids. Like do you think you would have been drawn to it anyway? There's no doubt that I had a real passion for it because I got to grow up around it, right? Did I? Yeah, yeah, yeah. He was my hero, my dad, favorite quarterback, all of that. But it was never a plan.
其实完全相反。他只是把我们当普通孩子养。就像你觉得你本来就会对这感兴趣吗？毫无疑问我对它有着真正的热情，因为我是伴随着它长大的，对吧？是吗？对，对，对。他是我的英雄，我的父亲，最喜欢的四分卫，诸如此类。但这从来不是什么计划。
It was never like, hey, Peyton, we're gonna go run two miles this morning. Like, you know, people used to say, about that, having me watchin' film as a fifth grader, like that is total bullshit. Like, completely made up. And they, you know, I mean, you tried to raise normal kids, and maybe that's why I ended up happening
从来不是那种，嘿，佩顿，我们今天早上要去跑两英里。就像，你知道的，人们以前谈论的那样，说我五年级时就在看比赛录像，这完全是胡扯。纯粹是瞎编的。而且他们，你知道的，我是说，你试着去抚养正常的孩子，也许这就是为什么最终会这样
because it wasn't some master plan, right? And it wasn't forced upon you, yeah. Absolutely not. And dumb question, worst injury ever. I've had neck problems during my time with the Colts and several surgeries that. Oh, really? I must have been scary.
因为这不是什么宏伟的计划，对吧？而且它不是强加给你的，对吗？绝对不是。还有一个蠢问题，受过的最严重的伤是什么。我在效力小马队期间有过颈部问题，并做过几次手术。哦，真的吗？那一定很吓人。
Yeah, because neck takes everything, right? I remember that. I remember that. Yeah, the doctors that I went to, I basically like challenged them to tell me, like, they tell me, I can play anymore. And that's the end of it. Like I will walk away today. I'm not going to, I want to be healthy for the rest of my life. And I mean, they just wouldn't say it. They said, Hey, your neck actually is secure. You have nerve damage in your right arm. So I had weakness. That was
对，因为脖子承受了一切，对吧？我记得。我记得。对，我去看过的医生，我基本上就像是向他们发出挑战，让他们告诉我，他们告诉我，我不能再踢球了。那就这样吧。我今天就会转身离开。我不会去冒险，我想在余生中保持健康。我的意思是，他们就是不肯这么说。他们说，嘿，你的脖子其实很稳固。你右臂有神经损伤。所以我有虚弱感。那
kind of my issue. But you know, I remember the doctor that I trusted most is like, Peyton, if you were my own son, I tell you, you are clear to play. If you get your strength back, you know, you're good doctor that I trusted most, he's like, Peyton, if you were my own son, I'd tell you, you are a clear deploy. If you get your strength back, you're good to go. And so that's kind of what it was for me. By the way, by the way, it should be no sorry, just so we'll stay on the next thing. I'm not kidding. Chappy, Mark Chappellus, my buddy and writing partner in England is a friend of the show.
算是我的问题。但你知道的，我最信任的医生说，佩顿，如果你是我的亲生儿子，我就会告诉你，你完全可以上场。如果你恢复了力量，你知道的，你就可以……最信任的医生说，佩顿，如果你是我的亲生儿子，我会告诉你，你完全可以上场。如果你恢复了力量，你就可以大干一场了。所以这对我来说就是那样的。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，不应该有，抱歉，为了让我们继续聊下一件事。我没开玩笑。查比，马克·查佩勒斯，我在英国的好友兼写作搭档，也是本节目的朋友。
He literally texted me 10 minutes ago out of the blue. He says, in the end, I decided to have surgery on my problematic muscle in my neck. Oh wow. Dot, dot, dot, I never looked back. Very nice. That's a joke. Thank you, Chad.
他就在10分钟前莫名其妙地给我发了一条短信。他说，最后，我决定对脖子上那个有问题的肌肉做手术。哦，哇。省略号，我从未回头。非常好。这是个玩笑。谢谢你，查德。
Out of the blue. So with you and Eli, kind of boldly going into a lane that your father had already been incredibly successful in, it's just, I think it's really incredible that you guys had the courage to do that, knowing that you're probably going to be unfairly judged, and then had incredible results. Can you talk a little bit about what that process was making that calculation and then what it felt like when you guys did so well? Yeah, I mean, we didn't know how it was going to turn out because there was no kind of
莫名其妙。所以，你和伊利，相当大胆地涉足了一个你们的父亲已经取得巨大成功的领域，我认为你们有勇气这样做真的很不可思议，明知自己可能会受到不公正的评判，然后还取得了不可思议的成果。能谈谈你们当时做出这个决定的心路历程，以及当你们做得如此出色时的感受吗？是的，我的意思是，我们不知道结果会怎样，因为对于我们要做的
baseline for what we were doing. And I knew doing it with Eli Jason was the only way to do it, right? You talk about chemistry amongst broadcast partners. Like, I know Eli very well. He makes fun of me very well, often a lot. I mean, the forehead jokes, they get a little old. I'm like, get some new material. I think that gave us a chance kind of coming out of the blocks that we see football the same way.
事情没有任何基准。我知道和伊利·杰森一起做这件事是唯一的出路，对吧？你谈到了转播搭档之间的默契。就像，我很了解伊利。他很擅长取笑我，而且经常这样。我的意思是，额头梗都有点老套了。我就想，换点新素材吧。我想这让我们在一开始就有了同样的视角来看待橄榄球。
Eli and I used to have these conversations on the bus after a coach or Giants game, and we could just talk about the play from one of our games and I can see it. I didn't have to write it down. He didn't have to screen shot a picture of the defense. I'm like, I got it. And so we still kind of can see it that same way.
我和伊利以前在教练或巨人队比赛后的巴士上会有这样的对话，我们可以只谈论我们某场比赛中的一个战术，然后我就能想象出来。我不需要把它写下来。他不需要截取防守阵型的图片。我就想，我懂了。所以我们现在仍然可以用那种相同的方式来看待它。
But look, I love talking football with people who love football as much as I do. And Snoop Dogg is football. There's a little more smoke coming out of Snoop's Zoom than there is kind of least. But he loves football, so it's all good. So, yeah, look, it's not for everybody. You know, I think people go back and forth between the main broadcast and the B team, which, you know, I think ESPN just wants you watching one of their channels.
但听着，我喜欢和像我一样热爱橄榄球的人谈论橄榄球。而斯蒂普·道格就是橄榄球的化身。斯蒂普的Zoom会议里冒出的烟可能比雷斯还要多一点。但他热爱橄榄球，所以一切都很好。所以，是的，听着，这并不适合所有人。你知道的，我认为人们会在主转播和B组转播之间摇摆不定，你知道的，我认为ESPN只是想让你观看他们的其中一个频道。
But I think one thing is clear that Eli and I are having fun doing it. And so I think if they see us having fun, maybe the viewer has fun as well. So maybe that's why it's worked. But it's a fun way to stay close to the game. But he and I like celebrating the positive accomplish. We're not looking to rip anybody. We'd rather say great play by the defensive back as opposed to what a horrible throw by the quarterback because we've been there, right? We've phoned all those interceptions.
但有一点很清楚，我和伊利在做这件事时玩得很开心。所以我想如果他们看到我们玩得很开心，观众可能也会觉得开心。所以也许这就是为什么它成功了吧。但这是一种与这项运动保持紧密联系的有趣方式。但他和我喜欢庆祝积极的成就。我们不是为了抨击任何人。我们宁愿说防守后卫干得漂亮，而不是说四分卫的传球太糟糕了，因为我们经历过，对吧？我们都传出过那些拦截球。
So, you know, that's kind of amazing. So, no, I appreciate it. It's infectious, man. Yeah, it's really good. Keep it up, keep going. Thank you for your time today And maybe we'll see you down the road you can you can watch my process up close and my incredible waggle I can't wait. I can't wait. Thanks for having me guys. All right, thanks. Thanks for coming very kind to me. All right, bye buddy, right
所以，你知道的，这真的很神奇。所以，不，我很感激。这很有感染力，伙计。是的，真的很棒。保持下去，继续加油。谢谢你今天抽出时间，也许我们在路上会遇到你。你可以近距离观察我的流程和我不可思议的扭臀。我等不及了。我等不及了。谢谢你们邀请我。好的，谢谢。谢谢你们的到来，对我太好了。好的，再见，伙计，好的。
How great is Pete Manning? I mean JB great one. Great guest. Well? I mean, Jamie, great one, great cast. Well, I mean, listen, it's, this is the greatest thing about this podcast. You get to sit there and you get to talk to these heroes. I mean, I fan out on everybody we have on this show. Wow, you get to sit with myself, you're a hero. Well, but the Be Pressing Company definitely excluded.
皮特·曼宁有多棒？我是说，JB太棒了。很好的嘉宾。好吧？我的意思是，杰米，太棒了，很棒的嘉宾。好吧？我的意思是，听着，这是这个播客最棒的地方。你可以坐在那里，和这些英雄交谈。我的意思是，我们节目请来的每一个人我都成了他的粉丝。哇，你能和我坐在一起，你就是个英雄。好吧，但贝·普雷斯公司绝对要除外。
Oh. You know, you get, when are we gonna to have a chance to talk to Peyton Manning and, and, and I need like a little, little, little boy asking him all these questions? Now that I'm older, I'm actually a fan. Yeah. I was, I was always, always a fan of his, always, always. I just, I love the way he did. And I thought he was really funny.
哦。你知道的，什么时候我们才有机会和皮特·曼宁谈话，而且，而且，我需要像个小男孩一样问他所有这些问题？现在我长大了，我真的是他的粉丝。是的。我一直，一直都是他的粉丝，一直都是。我只是，我喜欢他的做事风格。而且我觉得他真的很有趣。
Um, but B, I love the way he played football. And then see when he did get injured and came back from it and won a Super Bowl, that was fucking rad. Was that the neck? Well, the neck injury. Yeah. Oh, wow. And people were worried, he talked about, I mean, kind of downplayed it, people were worried
嗯，但是B，我喜欢他打橄榄球的方式。然后C，当他受伤后复出并赢得超级碗时，那真是太酷了。那是脖子吗？嗯，颈部受伤。是的。哦，哇。人们很担心，他谈到了，我的意思是，有点低估了它，人们很担心
about whether he'd be able to throw that well again and stuff. And he would get hit, does that, does that hit, you know? And it just, Sean, it kind of goes to what you were talking about, like having that, whatever that thing is of being a leader. Yeah. Like he's got so much confidence in his own ability to bounce back and not to just walk around, but to bounce back and win a super ball. Yeah.
他是否还能像以前那样传球等等。他会遭到撞击，那种撞击，你知道吗？肖恩，这就像你刚才说的，那种具备某种特质的能力，也就是领导力。是的。就像他对自己的康复能力有着极大的信心，不仅是四处走动，而是能够复出并赢得超级碗。是的。
Yeah. You know exactly how that feels. Yeah. I guess you do. Hey, you know the song, I like short shorts. Does it apply to, I guess, I do you like? I'll show you a short back. Wait, is that underwear?
是的。你完全知道那种感觉。是的。我想你是知道的。嘿，你知道那首歌吗，我喜欢短裤。它适用于，我想，你喜欢吗？我给你看个短款。等等，那是内衣吗？
Is that what we're wearing today? These are my little golf shorts. My little gray ones. So we'll, we're going to wear darker ones today. Yes. Shades, good. Just longer ones. Will and I hosted a couple of friends of ours that are members at another golf course here
这就是我们今天穿的吗？这是我的小高尔夫短裤。我的小灰色短裤。所以我们今天会穿颜色更深的。是的。墨镜，不错。只是更长的。威利和我接待了这里的另一家高尔夫球场的会员朋友
in Los Angeles. One of whom's a big friend of the show has done two episodes, a live episode end in studio. And so we'll have the idea that yesterday that we should show up and intimidate them by wearing matching outfits. And so we did. We did. We did.
在洛杉矶。其中一位是本节目的超级粉丝，已经录制了两期节目，一期是现场直播一期是在录音室。所以威利昨天就有了这个想法，我们应该穿着情侣装出现来吓唬他们。于是我们就这么做了。我们做了。我们做了。
Blue pants and a white shirt, white shoes white hat. Can you say who it is or no? Unimportant, but now we're going to their course today. Their course allows shorts. So yes, it's that guy. So we're going to wear some shorts today. It looks like well, yes. We're going to wear short.
蓝裤子配白衬衫、白鞋、白帽子。你能说出他是谁吗？不重要，但我们今天要去他们的球场。他们的球场允许穿短裤。所以是的，就是那个家伙。所以我们今天要穿短裤。看起来，是的。我们要穿短裤。
So these are the light gray. Also have a bit of a darker gray short. Do you have any that are your size? No, they all came in a boy's medium. Yeah. So why don't we rethink the, no, sit back down. We got it. Yep.
所以这些是浅灰色的。还有点深灰色的短裤。你有合适你尺码的吗？没有，它们都是男孩均码的。好吧，那我们为什么不重新考虑一下，不，坐回座位去。我们搞定了。是的。
And the granemals is that you match the top because they're granemals. I tell you what, Sean, we're going to go. We're going to play and don't worry afterwards. I'm going to give you the full play. Bye. Bye. Play. Well done.
还有那些格尼莫尔斯套装（Garanimals），你搭配上衣是因为它们是格尼莫尔斯套装。我跟你说，肖恩，我们要去了。我们要去打球，别担心，打完后。我会给你完整的复盘。再见。再见。打得好。
With an assist to Rob Armjav. Rob Armjav. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Flies. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav,
由罗布·阿尔姆贾夫协助。罗布·阿尔姆贾夫。微笑。微笑。微笑。微笑。飞翔。Smartless是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆贾夫
and Bennett Barberco. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early early on Amazon music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. I'm Carrie Mulligan, the host of I Hear Fear, a new anthology series of terror. The stories in this podcast are things that people don't want to talk about when the sun's out, and the world's supposed to make sense. But you and I know better, don't we?
和贝内特·巴尔科共同100%有机纯手工打造的。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或Wondry应用上的Wondry Plus提前收听且无广告。我是凯瑞·穆里根，全新恐怖选集系列《我闻到恐惧》的主持人。这个播客里的故事都是人们在太阳出来、世界本该合乎情理时不想谈论的事情。但你我都心知肚明，对吧？
We know that the best horror stories are the ones we tell each other in the dark, so turn off your lights and close your eyes. In each episode of Eye Hear Fear, you'll be treated to a new psychological thriller, a forest monster who lures teens into the woods and never lets them return. A line of beauty products that takes the search for youth to dark extremes.
我们知道最好的恐怖故事是我们在黑暗中彼此讲述的故事，所以关掉灯，闭上眼睛。《我闻到恐惧》的每一集都会为你带来一个新的心理惊悚故事，一个将青少年诱入树林且永不让他们返回的森林怪物。一个将对青春的追求推向黑暗极端的美容产品系列。
And an EDM party that turns deadly when the DJ takes over more than just the dance mall. Strap in, as these twisted stories and paranormal events take you on a suspenseful and thrilling ride. I hear fear will introduce immersive horror and lead you straight into the heart of darkness. Follow I Hear Fear on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcast. You can listen to I Hear Fear early in At Free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有一场EDM派对，当DJ接管的不仅仅是舞池时，派对变得致命。系好安全带，这些扭曲的故事和超自然事件将带你踏上一段悬疑惊悚之旅。《我闻到恐惧》将带你领略沉浸式恐怖，并将你直接带入黑暗的心脏。在Wondry应用或任何你获取播客的地方关注《我闻到恐惧》。通过加入Wondry Plus，你现在就可以提前且无广告收听《我闻到恐惧》。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。